Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello!
I apologize that this is a very early stream for Resident Evil 4.
I wanted to start early today because I was like, okay, if we're doing a long stream, I don't want to get to the scary part when it's nighttime.
I want to get to the scary part when the sun is just going down.
So that is why.
I know it's a different time slot compared to like the part one of Resident Evil 4.
But like, guys, it is for the sake of my sanity that we play the game when it's not that scary.
When it's not dark.
So...
It's not cheating!
It's the sky!
So that is why we are playing it at an earlier time slot.
Because, like I said, I don't want to, you know, I don't want to get to the scary...
Like, if we're doing a long stream, most likely some of the scarier parts happen at a later time.
So like, you know, maybe if I play for a long stream, I'm going to get to the scary part.
Like if I play for like five or six hours.
And it's scary, I can look outside and be like, oh, the sun is still out.
So like this is not real.
When it gets dark, I can be like, I'll be like, there's a possibility this can happen.
But when I see that the sun is still out, I'd be like, it's not real because the sun is still out.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Perfect time for EU.
Almost set to 9pm.
They gave us a superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, so this is... this is...
Whenever I do play Visage, I'm gonna make sure it's the 12.30pm slot.
Because there's no fucking way I'm playing Visage when there's sun and it's out.
There's no fucking way.
You can't make me.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I already forgot all the controls, by the way.
So this is... you guys gotta help me.
I already... I actually forgot all the fucking controls for this game.
It's... after like a day, I just forgot how to play video games in general.
Oh, this part.
Okay, we can... I mean, we can rewatch this.
Left click does stuff.
Oh shit, really?
Oh my god!
Oh yeah, he like... he got like injected with things.
He became Coca-Cola Bear.
Oh yeah, it's Adam Sadler!
Trina, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the superchat.
Passed Doki, made the right choice.
Have lots of fun, Doki.
Can't catch the stream right now, but I'll definitely watch the VOD.
Or chapter 5 that I'm making.
I'll check it on time later.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel you.
I'm thinking of the 20 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
How to melee.
I'll figure this out.
I'm not alright.
Ma'am, I got injected by Coca-Cola Bear.
Or by Adam Sadler.
I don't know which is worse.
Oh, F.
I figured it out.
F is melee.
I figured it out, guys.
I... okay.
The only other... the only other way I hate playing when the sun is out is that it makes me realize just how dirty my monitor is.
Because when the sun shines just right...
On your monitor.
Too real.
That's the only thing I hate about mothaflame.
When the sun is out.
When it sunshines just right.
You can see everything on your mo...
I'm gonna fucking... give me a sec, guys.
I need to close my blinds.
I can't... I can't feel like... I don't wanna see.
I don't wanna see how fucked up my monitor is.
Alright.
It's okay.
The sun is still shining through my blinds.
Because...
There we go.
I feel less guilty now.
Ah, shit.
I forgot there was... this was the reason why I stopped playing.
I forgot that this was the reason.
Where the fuck is my map?
Okay.
Where do I go?
Okay, I'm gonna go to the dead end?
Is this dead end?
This is dead end.
Okay.
There must be like loot, right?
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, no.
I'm turning.
I'm hearing the voices.
Oh, no.
I didn't take my meds.
Oh.
Ohhhhhhh.
I don't like this.
Come out the bush!
Oh, loot.
Ohhhhhhh.
This is why I play in the morning!
Okay.
Oh, I'm lost.
Oh, I'm freaking out that I don't even know where to go.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Stop!
I'll never take my meds!
Oh, hey.
Barrow.
Okay, I need to take the barrow first.
Barrow time.
Oh.
Oh, the voices are only in that area.
If I close my eyes.
Okay.
Money.
Oh.
Hello?
Who's there?
Whoa!
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
Oh, the voices are back.
The voices are back.
Get out of the bush!
Oh, no.
What are they even saying?
Oh, there's the bones.
There's the bones.
Oh, there they are.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
What's going on?
What?
Oh!
Oh, that's a sniper!
Oh, shit!
Where do I shoot?
The head?
He has no head!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, you have a head though.
Oh, God.
There you go.
I think that's your head.
Oh, what?
Okay.
If I shoot that, that's your head.
If I shoot the leg... if I shoot the leg!
You can't walk, right?
Okay.
Okay, nope.
Alright.
Shotgun time.
If it all fails, it's shotgun time.
Oh no.
What flashbang?
I don't work... oh there it is.
That flash.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Register shortcut.
Alright, there.
I'll put that here.
Alright, I don't have a lot... I don't have a lot of fucking shotgun ammo.
That's great.
I should have not shot the knees when that thing came out.
Alright.
Well, I assume that headshots don't work right now.
I assume that headshots do not work on these guys.
Craft.
Oh, I don't have enough shotgun.
Wait, do I not have enough?
I should have enough.
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna make shotgun shells.
We're gonna need it.
Alright.
They do?
Oh, they do work?
Oh, okay.
So I just keep aiming the head.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, they still have brains in there.
Okay, that's good.
I couldn't tell!
There were like so many things coming out of the head!
I don't know, maybe there were like mini brains in like various areas.
Like, what's... I don't know the logic of parasites.
Like...
I don't know the logic of Resident Evil 4 parasites.
How would I know?
Cause I already killed the brain!
Where are the other brains?
Like, where...
Where are the mini brains?
Aim for the head tentacles.
I don't know that!
Are there mini brains in the tentacles?
Am I supposed to assume that?
They are weak to...
Yeah!
Okay.
Yeah, but will they die from light?
They might be weak to light, but will they... they won't die from it!
That's the thing!
I need Tetris this.
This is like so fucking messy.
Wait, is that a chocolate bar?
What is this?
Oh, it's an rifle.
I was like, why do I have a chocolate bar?
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Where do I go?
I'm already lost.
Oh, I go...
Oh, wait, what?
There was a way over here?
Oh.
Oh, I can barely see!
It's...
Like, the thing I hate is that Leon doesn't turn on his fucking flashlight!
Like, when it's clearly very...
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Who's there?
I have a shotgun!
Leon, please!
Just turn on your fucking flashlight!
It's so dark!
Like...
It's... I'm turning on this brightness.
I can't.
I'm fucking blind right now.
I can't fucking deal with this, Leon.
Leon, please!
All I ask you is to turn on your fucking flashlight!
Jesus Christ, Leon!
Okay.
I guess a little better.
Oh my god, this is so much...
Oh, thank you!
Thank you!
Okay, what is this place?
Leon eats his carrots.
Fuck carrots.
What's carrots done for me?
The Shrine of Hands.
Firmly grasp it.
Same mark from the church.
Is this the hand guard?
What the fuck do I put in there?
Alright, it's time to figure it fine out.
Oh god!
Okay, there's a boat.
I don't like this.
God, I hate this level so fucking much.
Do I put the head?
Oh, there's the monster I killed!
Oh!
What's in here?
Wait, there's treasures?
Oh, there's a lot of treasures.
Okay, we're gonna have to go there.
And then we have to go there to grab stuff.
Uh...
Oh my god, why is there...
Why is there a maze-like thing here?
I don't like that.
Alright, and then...
So we go there.
And then...
Oh wait, but there's like loot in the middle of the lake!
How do I get to the middle?
I can't fucking swim apparently.
Wait, is that the right game?
Oh no, all the games are blurring together.
No, I can't swim.
No, Leon can swim, nevermind.
Sorry.
All the games are blurring together because usually I can't swim.
We have to manually drive the boat myself?
That's fucked up.
Why do I have to drive the boat myself?
That's what the game is for.
That's what cutscenes are for.
Are you telling me I don't get the privilege of cutscenes?
Okay.
Someone fetched me a rare golden chicken egg.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Well, time to see if the chickens will lay me an egg.
Uh, what's in here?
What are you?
The old way shrine.
What door does this open?
All the locations are...
I can't remember, man.
Wait, I do have to drive the boat!
What?
Where's my cutscene privileges?
Oh, no.
I have to throw the fucking spear too?
Goddamn.
I'm so sad.
There's no cutscene privileges.
I have to do this all by hand.
Boop.
I guess I'll grab that $100.
Oh, it's $100 now?
I remember when barrels were $1000.
Inflation happened.
Do you remember?
Okay, isn't that the boat?
Oh, this was the boat.
Oh, okay.
I have to get in this boat.
How the hell do I get on this boat?
Hello?
Oh, here.
I heard there's a gun here.
Thank you, backseaters.
Alright.
Gun?
No, that is...
Alexandrite.
Gun?
Dang, I can't believe I have to play the game.
Oh my god!
Where is the gun?
Did my backseaters lie to me?
Gun?
Oh, this must be gun.
Is that the pistol?
Wait, is that a pistol?
Is that a better pistol?
Okay, red.
A powerful handgun.
It is burned to a grip to prevent the user from loading.
Wait, is that a better pistol?
Can I like attach this to...
Wait, where's the other?
Is this the...
Okay.
SG...
What is the SG?
Oh, this one.
Is that...
Does it use pistol ammo?
Strongest?
Okay, alright.
Well, goodbye.
We're gonna...
Oh.
Oh, I don't...
It only goes to that gun?
Okay.
Equipped.
Shortcut.
Bam.
How much ammo do I have?
Oh, it is.
But there's no...
There's no laser though.
Best damage for slow reload?
Okay, I'm gonna put this in the storage then.
Goodbye.
What was that quote?
I'm done playing with you.
Goodbye.
Wait, wait, wait.
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
Where do we go?
The Lakeside settlement.
Wait, what in the fuck is...
Door with Insignia.
Oh, there's so many things there.
Have I been here before?
What's over there?
There's a door with Insignia.
Oh, wait.
Is that the...
Oh my god.
There's a hidden area here too.
Okay, wait.
This is important.
I'm done with...
There's so much loot.
There is so much loot.
Thank god this is...
Thank god the sun is out.
Okay.
It's this way.
Right?
Yeah, it's this way.
It's over here.
I have to always tab to look at the map because I'm stupid.
Alright, here we go.
Yay!
I'm back.
Oh, there's chickens!
There's so many chickens.
Chicken, chicken, time to lay some egg.
Time to lay some golden eggs.
What's this?
Do I even have enough?
Okay, yeah, I do.
Alright.
Guys.
Guys, this is it.
This is your job.
To lay me some eggs.
Come on.
I can wait all day.
Okay.
I can just do super chat reading.
Come on, chickens.
Oh, there we go.
Alright.
I don't need you anymore.
Oh my god, that's way too many eggs.
Give me a sec.
I'm done with all of you two.
No, it's a waste of bullets.
Okay.
Sorry.
That's actually a waste of bullets.
You're not worth my time.
Let's see.
How the fuck do I get over to this?
Oh, I have to go through here.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the merchant?
Merchant.
Oh, I have to...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I need to like...
Okay, you know what?
No.
I'm gonna go over here and grab some more treasures.
Treasure time.
What?
You don't eat chicken?
You can't say that.
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait.
I don't even have to fucking...
Why do I even need to use my fucking thing?
I can just ram into it.
You can't say that unless you're vegan or vegetarian.
If you're neither of these, you can't say that.
Because you've eaten KFC before.
Don't think I don't know.
There you go.
Not that...
Where do you think fucking fried chicken comes from?
Chicken?
Where do you think fried chicken came from?
Is that Indiana Jones?
Okay.
Bro, it takes like 20 years to die.
All right.
Here you go.
Oh wait, I heard the reload.
It's like... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
The reload!
Okay, now I understand what you mean by the reload being like super low.
Shink!
I fucked up the shink!
Guys, I fucked up the shink because I saw the thing and I was like I should press like...
I didn't realize it would take that... I didn't realize it would take that long to shink somebody.
That was... that was an oopsie there.
I would admit I might have messed up a little there.
There was a quick time prompt and I chose...
I chose to ignore it because I thought I would shink faster.
I thought I was faster than the quick time prompt.
Uh, light?
There we go.
I legitimately thought I was faster.
Oh man, there's definitely people here.
Oh man, I could feel it.
I'm gonna go in there later.
What?
Can we go back to the lake when it's daytime?
Is that possible?
Do we come back here?
Do we come back here when it's daytime?
What's the point?
Why did they give the five gift shins thinking they hate you?
We don't?
That's fucked up.
That actually is fucked up, man.
That's...
That's fucked up, man.
I wish we came back here when it was daytime.
Alright, use.
There is no sun.
Sad.
I'm so sad.
We don't have space anymore?
I don't even...
Mike, thank you for that one gifted shin.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
Let us...
We'll go... We'll do the...
Oh my god.
I don't wanna do the house, man.
Why...
Why is it so dark?
No...
There's people here.
There's no way a house like this is empty.
When there's so much loot.
There's no way... I refuse to believe this house is unoccupied.
Oh my god.
I don't have any keys.
Wait.
Is it even worth it?
I don't...
Oh my god.
Does this need a key?
This... Do I have the key for this?
It's just fish.
It's a fishing village.
Oh my god.
Oh...
No key for that one?
Alright.
This does not look like an empty house.
This looks like a house...
Wait.
Have I already...
Yeah.
I've already fucking done that.
This looks like a house that's about to fucking gank me.
Hello?
Hello, guys?
Is this... Is this the photo?
Oh, this... I put that there.
Oh, I hate this.
I hate this so much!
I don't feel safe.
You say I'm safe, but I definitely do not feel safe.
Oh my god.
There's a ladder.
Bro.
How worth of it... How...
How worth it is it for me to go there?
Oh!
How worth it?
How worth?
It's so worth... Alright.
How much do you wanna bet?
Guys.
How much do you wanna bet this?
Of how worth this is?
Are you willing to bet?
Bet for it?
Alright.
I'm going in.
I'm running in.
I don't care.
I'm not looking.
I'm running in.
If I don't look...
Wait.
What?
Oh.
It was worth it.
That's money!
Three years ago, my beloved daughter passed away shortly after giving birth to a son.
Since then, the boy has grown considerably.
He's a very curious child and has a true thirst for knowledge.
He even tries to follow after me when I go out hunting.
I can't take my eyes off him for a second.
Whenever we walk in the forest, he always asks me to tell stories.
He's very fond of Don.
Although he's small, the boy is smart and observant beyond his years.
If he weren't stuck here, he might become a scholar.
I was a careless fool.
I could have sworn I shot clean through the wolf's head.
And yet, it lunged at me.
I was able to make it back to the cabin.
But my wound is swollen and discolored.
I cannot bear seeing the boy's worried eyes.
My body moves on its own.
Oh no!
He got infected by the bad wolves!
My boy moves on its own.
My body... Am I going mad?
I can't die now and leave the boy behind.
Dear God, please protect him.
Oh.
Bro...
I can't go back!
Oh my God!
Not the walk back!
Whose shoes are those?
Oh my God!
Not the walk back, please protect me!
I hate this.
Oh my God!
I fucking hate this house.
Put me back in the forest!
At least there's like sky.
You know?
At least the sky is out.
My paranoia.
It's rising.
Okay, here we go.
Missed opportunity for optional bikinis for Leon.
Modders, do you hear that?
To be fair, I don't think I've seen like a mod for like a naked Leon.
Like, you know, shirtless Leon.
Let me phrase that better.
A shirtless Leon.
I do not think I've ever seen a mod for it.
Alright.
Let's see.
I saw a lot of mods for Ashley though.
That's like...
Why do you not give us what we really want?
Shirtless Leon!
Where is my shirtless Leon?
Oh, wait.
I didn't open this before.
There is?
Oh my god, Link!
For scientific reasons.
For research purposes.
Wait, what is over here?
I've never been here before.
What would be here?
Guys, for research purposes.
I need to know what to look for.
Guys, it is clearly for research.
Can someone cast a gigantic fish that lives in the lake for me?
Wait.
Oh!
I just have to shoot it.
Sell it.
Wait, don't I have one?
Yeah, isn't that the... Oh, it's the Lunker Bass.
Okay, not the other one.
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, it's the Lunker Bass.
What the fuck is over here?
Ashley?
Oh, that is not Ashley.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
What the hell is going on here?
What is this?
Who are you?
You're not my hot topic, Ashley.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
I don't really like that.
Wait, the mod is called shirtless Leon.
Wait, they actually have shirtless Leon?
Oh.
Guys, what if I...
I finally saved it.
I won't, guys.
Don't worry.
I won't do that.
I still want to be monetized, everybody.
I still want to be monetized.
What's up here, though?
What's up here?
I didn't even realize they actually do have it.
Those mad men.
Horse altar?
Wait, they're all women.
Is that what Ashley's for?
Oh, I don't like it.
I feel like I'm gonna get fucking...
I got key.
Oh, that must have been for the chest.
Oh my god.
Dude, I'm getting so paranoid from all of this.
I feel so much paranoia right now.
I don't feel safe.
Wait, where is that?
I hear it, but where is it?
You hear that, right?
Where is it?
Where?
You hear that, right?
You hear the toy?
I swear I'm not fucking going crazy.
Oh, there!
There he is!
Oh yeah, there he is.
Oh my god, I just...
Why?
I'm so paranoid!
There's so much paranoia!
I feel...
I shouldn't feel this safe.
I don't feel safe at all.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Shoutout to the Trampstab Leon mod and to the Redacted mod too.
Thank you!
Why do you know so much about that, D-Dragon?
Why do you know that?
Huh?
Hmm...
You know, when I was researching mods...
Those were definitely not downloaded a lot.
Hmmm...
Oh no!
It's the evil wolf!
It's super evil wolf!
Is evil wolf dead?
Oh no.
Super wolves...
I'm not ready for super wolves!
Isn't that super?
Oh, what the fuck?
They're working together!
Oh shit.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, that's on me.
All right.
Okay, how the fuck do I miss that, though?
Like ohhhhh Okay, I'm just gonna use my shotgun, fuck this.
This is like way too much work.
Alright, come over here, come over here.
BOOM!
Nice, okay.
Alright.
Okay, I did not like Super Wolf.
I did not like Super Wolf at all.
Super Wolf did not make me comfortable.
Alright, let's craft some more shotgun shells here.
Alright, nice.
Uhh...
We'll just eat an egg.
We have so many eggs.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your face is so smug.
Can't decide if I want to protect you or bully you.
Good job, Boat Babysitting.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jesus Christ, not Super Wolf.
Uh, where is here?
Is this important?
I guess we're treasure?
Oh, there's a typewriter there.
Like, how important is here?
How... how important is here?
Not yet?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I guess we leave.
I guess we're fine.
We already killed Super Wolves.
Oh, we have to unlock this chest though.
Turn on your light.
There we go.
Thank you, Leon.
Alright.
You should have the key now for this.
What is it?
Ah, gold bar.
Nice.
There's so much money.
I like money.
Just like Mr. Krabs, my Oshie.
Alright, here we go.
You'll be around back to the village eventually?
What are you... you guys just told me I would never be back here!
That's why I fucking went here!
That's the only reason why I went there.
Because you guys said it wouldn't be important.
Can't believe it.
Would this be important?
Guys, is this entrance important enough, guys?
I need to know!
It's complicated.
Is this entrance important?
Yes?
Okay, now I'm feeling... do it for the money?
Okay, but how much money though?
Like...
Like, is it worth the ammo?
Like here.
Right here.
Is it worth the ammo for this?
Well, I mean I could like fucking...
Boop.
Alright.
Oh, hey, there's a lot of money.
Hey, there is money.
Boop.
I think I'm gonna die in this cave.
Bro, I feel like I'm just gonna fucking die in this cave.
Oh, hey, look!
There is money!
Look at that!
All the money!
Oh, but I could open here!
But there is a typewriter here.
Maybe I should just go for the typewriter here.
Oh my god, I...
Oh my god, do not feel safe in here.
I feel like this cave is just gonna collapse.
This is like a bait cave.
This does not feel like the safe cave.
It feels like the bait cave.
Okay.
Oh, there is a place for me to dock my boat.
Is this the one with the gators?
What do you mean by that?
What the fuck?
Excuse me?
What do you mean?
Is this the one with the gators?
There is crocodiles now?
Or alligators?
I don't fucking care.
They are basically the same thing.
Oh my god, man.
Don't worry about it.
Gators in Europe?
Oh my god, true.
What the fuck?
How are you here?
Who brought you here?
Are you an invasive species?
Alright.
I'm gonna go to the other side.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Did I grab all the treasure?
I did.
Alright, then I fucking...
just ride back to over here.
Oh, I saw that treasure over here too.
Oh no, they've escaped from the zoo.
Oh no.
Bro, I haven't made any progress on the story.
I've just been looting, man.
I've made zero progress from this.
This is why I started this early today.
Thank you.
I've just been looting.
Treasure over Ashley.
I still have yet to fucking find Ashley.
This whole game is about protecting Ashley.
And I'm definitely not doing my job.
Alright, here we go.
Like, the president purposely hired me to save Ashley.
But I'm just here looting.
Alright, nice.
I am...
Nice!
Wait.
There is a chest here, right?
That can open.
Can I open this now?
No, I don't have the key.
God damn it.
Alright, sir.
I got the golden egg!
Sounding like you're the super chat.
Thank you.
Gator, I hardly know her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I got something new for you.
I got you that...
What the fuck?
Okay, that's a lot of shit.
That's a lot of shit.
Okay, let me give you the golden chicken egg first.
This is what I'm talking about.
Nice.
Fine work.
Where would it...
You're right.
She's probably fine.
Come back.
She's probably okay, guys.
I don't know why you guys are so worried.
Probably okay.
Okay, what's the matchup?
1.2 for different colors.
Okay, I have different colors.
Boop.
Alright, nice.
Now you're more pretty.
Alright.
Cool.
Elegant headdress.
Okay.
Wait, can I not...
Can I put you...
Yeah, let me put stones in you.
Excuse you.
Excuse me?
Let me...
Are that not stones?
Oh, they're not.
I thought...
Every time I see a circle, I think stone.
I was like, I can put stones in you.
Alright, there's not...
It looks like it had it.
Okay, I can sell this key now.
Okay.
And then I'll sell...
Oh my god, 12,000.
I'm fucking rich.
Okay, and then I'll sell this and I'll sell...
Oh my god, 19,000?
Guys, don't talk to me.
I'm...
Don't talk to me unless you have a splendid bangle.
Okay.
Alright, we can sell all of this.
Nice.
Okay.
Boop.
Oh my god!
93,000.
This is good.
Okay, we can get rid of...
Wait, can I get rid of my normal pistol now?
That money changed you.
Do I sell the...
Yeah, I can sell the SG.
Goodbye.
You're never coming back to me.
Alright, here you go.
Yeah, this one.
Okay, yeah.
Alright, I'll sell it.
Nice.
Alright.
Now I can just upgrade my new baby.
Okay.
How much is my durability right now?
You know, I have so much money.
I don't even care.
Alright, where is...
Where is my new baby?
Here you go.
Power.
Yes.
Okay, I heard the reload.
I need to up the reload speed, right?
Jesus, lonely clothes.
To the sun.
Okay, I can...
I'm going to get the reload speed because the reload speed for this is dog shit now.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
And then...
What else?
Uh...
You know what?
What else?
I have 81,000 I can do whatever the fuck...
No, I'm going to do the power for the knife too.
I'm so rich!
It doesn't matter!
I have so much load!
Oh, I should sell the...
I should sell the laser sight.
Which one is the laser sight?
Is it this one?
It's this one, right?
Uh...
What?
Is this one right?
Yeah, this is for the SG and the Punisher.
Wait, I have one for Punisher.
Is the Punisher better?
Or is my current gun better?
Chat.
Is the Punisher or this one better?
Don't store it?
We need...
Power is always a safe bet for it.
No?
No you don't...
Punisher sucks?
Okay, wait.
Oh my gosh, wait what?
What are these?
Leon with shotgun?
I can sell my... Oh!
I was gonna say!
I can sell myself?
But that's the charm.
Okay, I'll sell the laser sight.
Okay, I'm gonna sell it then.
I'm gonna do it!
I'm selling it!
You know what?
It's alright.
We have a lot of... We have so much money.
Okay, well let me see.
Oh, case upgrade!
We need that.
Okay.
Is that everything?
Well, let's attach... We don't need it.
What?
It's okay.
We don't need fucking grenades.
All we need is our...
Our fucking guns.
Like, we're not gonna take the cheap route with nades.
Also, I'm pretty sure I'm gonna nade myself anyways.
So I'm gonna...
I'm like...
I lowkey think...
I am definitely gonna like...
Accidentally grenade myself.
So I don't think I should...
Hahaha!
Flash grenade?
Oh, alright.
What do I add?
Ah, okay.
I'll buy it.
I have so much money.
I can waste money right now.
I can like... Okay.
I'm gonna upgrade the power.
Will I ever... Will I ever get a better gr...
Pista.
Will I ever get a better Pista?
Guys.
If not, I will...
Hahaha!
No?
Is this the best Pista?
I'm gonna get?
Yes?
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna all in.
All in!
All fucking in!
And I might as well get the reload speed.
Cause the reload speed is fucking slow.
Alright, now I'm poor.
Guys, now you can talk to me again.
Hahaha!
Unless you have that bangle.
Unless you have the bangle.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Uhhhhhhh.
Why the fuck would I want like a different case color?
Like what?
Hahaha!
I'm just like you guys.
I'm one of the people.
Hahaha!
I'm one of the people now!
Where the fuck is the typewriter?
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
Oh, there's a buff?
Wait, what?
Where's the buff?
Oh!
Increases the drop.
Wait, what?
Wait, do I buy it?
Aesthetic.
Wait, what's the white one?
What does the white one do?
What does the white case do?
How would I know?
How do I know what the fuck the white case does?
The case or the stock?
Don't buy it?
I was like, buy it!
Don't buy it.
Hahaha!
But what does the white case do?
I'm so curious.
What does it do?
Oh, increased drop rate for handguns!
Okay, no, the ammo is better.
The ammo is much better.
What the fuck?
Of course I would pick the ammo.
Yeah, the ammo is better than this.
Cass, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you saying we have no trash?
Hahaha!
Okay, I saved already.
Alright, uh...
I wanna go here.
There must be like stuff here too.
So...
Alright, nice.
My fucking... I'm so kinky now.
Am I going the right way?
I am.
Okay, that's good.
I always need to know if I'm going the right way.
God, this...
They do this ambient so well.
I'm like super fucking paranoid.
Every time.
Everywhere I go, I'm thinking, Am I gonna die here?
Am I?
Hahaha!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You mean Leon?
Yeah, search up the...
Search up Leon inflation.
Oh wait, this is where I was.
I don't have any...
Uh... I don't have this though.
Hahaha!
Alright, let's see.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Wow, I'm not telling you guys to search it up.
I'm talking about that one guy.
Hahaha!
I know what you're into.
Okay, let's see.
Mural... I need to go here.
Mural cave.
I need to go here.
And also... yeah, this one.
Alright, there you go.
Get the bass?
Where is that?
Okay, where's the...
Alright, we'll get that later.
That's not important, guys!
Let's see.
We have to go to...
this area to get the location.
There has to be people in there.
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
Sorry.
Hahaha!
I was too busy looking at my chat.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see.
Is this it?
Yeah, this is it.
Hahaha!
We're actually thinking about the super chat that you think.
Which way?
Okay.
I mean, obviously it can't be that easy, right?
Yeah, I fucking knew it.
I was like, there's no way it's that easy.
It never makes things easy for you.
Hahaha!
Alright, let's see.
Oh no, not the whispers!
Oh, okay.
It's just this guy.
Give me a sec, I'm reloading.
Okay, give me a sec.
Wait, where are you going?
Where... Okay.
Hahaha!
I was like, where are you going?
Alright, here you go.
Nice.
Is there more people coming over?
No?
Okay, I need to go see if there's loot here.
Wait, oh there is loot!
Nice, I fucking knew it.
Every time there's a little hole, there's loot.
Nice money!
I'll never be as rich as I was before.
I felt so strong.
Oh no!
Please, am I fast enough?
No!
I was too... No, I was fast enough!
I was not fast enough!
Okay.
No, my shotgun!
I was not fast enough, guys!
Alright, nice.
I will be fast enough.
Okay, I'm fast enough this time.
Guys.
I'm never fast enough.
Hello?
Alright.
Nice.
Mayday?
Oh, not nice.
Not nice.
That is a fucking bomb!
I didn't have time to shoot it!
It's okay.
We're fine here.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
They're burning themselves!
Yay!
More time to reload!
What?
What the fuck?
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Alright.
We're just gonna get you out of here.
Oh my god.
Please tell me you guys have more ammo later on.
My ammo resources is not good right now.
Wait.
Did he like, blew himself up?
That's really convenient.
Wait.
What happened to that one guy throwing bombs?
God.
God, I hate that ambience.
Alright.
We need more...
We always need more shotgun, man.
We always need more shotgun.
No!
We don't have enough!
Okay.
We gotta need five more.
Nice.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's see.
Hello?
Boop!
Oh, wait.
Is that it?
No.
Oh my god!
I don't need rifle ammo!
Hello?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello?
Okay.
What do I need to do?
Alright.
There's treasure here.
And then there's a shrine here.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Is this a rifle?
No!
This is a waste.
Rifle is for bosses only.
These guys are too small.
These guys are not worth it.
Are you... Are they a boss?
No!
I am trying to set a presidency here.
Okay?
They need to know their worth.
And they are not worth rifles.
They are not... They are... Dude, dude!
They are not worth rifle privileges!
Not everybody deserves to be a rifle!
What the fuck?
What?
Oh shit!
There he is!
I was like, what?
I'm so... Oh!
What the fuck!
Where did you get here?
Oh god.
I don't like this.
Oh!
I don't like this!
Mr. Gremlin!
Oh wait, I need to reload.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Don't!
Do not!
Okay.
Finally.
I only have one ammo.
One bullet.
One bullet and a dream.
Wait, is he dead?
Oh my god.
I hear so many things going on around me.
There's way too many sounds.
There's way too... Oh shit!
Okay!
Okay, there you go.
There's way too many sounds going on.
Oh, okay.
Thank god.
Please be handgun ammo.
Please be...
Nice!
Nice, okay.
Where the fuck am I?
What the fuck?
Okay.
We're okay.
We don't stealth in here.
Okay, can't go anywhere here.
Oh!
Oh, nice.
Alright, nice.
Okay, there's no such thing as stealth here in this neighborhood.
How the fuck do I get to this side?
Why is there...
Why did they paint it yellow?
I'm too stupid.
Why did they paint...
What does this mean?
I can't kick this!
The boxes were yellow!
That meant kick!
This is yellow!
What does this mean?
It's what it means!
Okay, I know what it means now.
Alright, this line and this line.
Okay.
Guys, I figured it out.
I know what it means now.
I figured it out.
I realized it was a puzzle.
Oh my god!
What the fuck is this stupid ass puzzle?
Look, I didn't look left, okay?
I didn't see there was a button right here.
I mean, how many times do I have to press this?
Oh, three!
There's three buttons?
Okay, this, this...
This, this...
This...
Okay, clear them.
Does it come in order?
Guys, is there an order to these buttons?
What could the buttons mean?
Okay.
There's like that.
Alright.
I know there's like one more guy.
There he is.
There he is lurking.
I knew you were still alive.
Nice.
That's fine.
I know like it might be a little waste of a bullet.
But it...
No!
He's too far from... No!
He was too far!
There you go.
Nice.
That has to be the last one.
The order is no ice action.
Back that view.
Fuck off.
Alright, let's see.
I only found two of these.
Oh, there's more loot.
There's more loot.
I love loot.
Nice.
Loot's my favorite.
Mehdi, what could the puzzle symbols mean?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wow!
Nice.
Woo!
You know what?
Bye.
If you live through this, I'll let you be rifled.
I'll let you be rifled.
Wait!
Shit!
I didn't see him behind me.
Okay.
Okay, I was like, I heard something behind me, but I was like, no.
There's no way.
I was like, wait a minute.
Okay, but look at those reflexes though.
Those were some sick ass reflexes.
You have to admit.
Those reflexes were pretty sick.
Alright.
Oh!
Circle!
And then...
And then that!
That was like two sides together.
Okay.
Circle!
It was like...
This!
Okay, it was not that.
What the fuck is it over there?
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
This is also circle.
This is...
Oh my god, I cannot remember the symbols on the top of my head.
What?
Every time I look at it, I forgot what it looks like.
Like...
Okay.
Double circle!
And then...
Wait, no?
This circle?
This circle.
And then this circle.
And then this?
No.
It's one of these circles!
Okay, it's not that circle.
Maybe it's this circle.
I can't remember the circles!
I already forgot the circles!
I know it's a circle!
Maybe this?
Okay, it's not that circle.
Maybe it's this circle.
Is it this circle?
Was it that circle?
Yeah!
I got it!
I knew it was one of the circles.
I fucking knew it!
God, I'm so smart!
Yay!
Guys!
I knew it was circle!
I just can't remember which circle!
I can't remember!
First try!
I did it!
Wait, there's more people?
Where did you come from?
Why are you still here?
What the fuck?
Woah!
Shit!
Where did those people come from?
Will it blow up?
Did he light it?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
You should be dead.
Where did you come from?
Alright.
Loot!
Nice.
Alright, are there any more surprise people?
Are there any more?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Doki has a unique way of pronouncing circle.
It's pretty cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
It's called the Doki accent.
The Doki scent.
It's called never really growing up around the world that you fucking absorb every accent possible.
Wait, what is that?
Did I miss something here?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, there were treasure here?
What the fuck?
How did I miss that?
Okay, I guess I go back.
I missed some treasure.
Treasure!
Oh no, that's a door!
Wait, but what is that over here?
There's like treasure right here.
God.
Here?
Can I miss some treasure?
Don't tell me I should have looked up.
Is it up treasure?
It has to be up treasure.
It's oh, is it this?
There's no way.
Are you treasure?
But you're just a lamp!
Oh no, you're treasure!
There you go.
I knew it.
I knew you were hiding from me.
Okay, I'm gonna reload just in case because the ammo here is so fucking slow.
Hey, we got one of the heads!
Look, money is important guys.
How else am I gonna keep upgrading my shit guys?
Leon deserves it.
Guys, Leon deserves it!
Oh my god.
Is there no reverse?
Is there no- Oh, it's- Okay, I was gonna say.
I was like, where's reverse?
Yes, reverse.
Ivy, thank you for the five!
Get the shivs!
Thank you!
Okay, we need a...
I'm gonna go save.
I don't trust my stuff.
I'm gonna go save real fast.
Don't worry guys, we will progress the story!
It might be an hour later!
But we will progress the story!
Do not worry!
We will meet Ashley soon!
Eventually!
Ashley will be here!
Okay.
Just trust!
Trust the process!
Okay, we gotta put these two together just in case.
And then...
Let's see...
Okay, we need to put this in here too.
Oh wait, no I can't combine it!
Because I'm so stupid!
Okay, we need a yellow herb.
Who is Ashley?
Oh, I'm so stupid!
We've been stuck on Chapter 4 for a while now.
Okay.
Guys, no, we need the loot!
We need the loot so we can upgrade!
It's all about the upgrades!
Think about the bloodline!
Think about it!
Noble, thank you for the super chat!
Guys, think about the bloodline!
How would Leon continue it if he isn't fucking jacked?
Alright, this is it.
Let's go... this way.
Upgrades, people!
Upgrades!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, here we go.
We have to go... oh wait, do the chickens lay new eggs?
Chickens!
Did you guys lay new eggs for me?
Sorry, this is a very important detour.
You won't understand.
Chickens!
What the fuck?
I left you guys there for an hour and you don't lay new eggs?
Guys...
You know what that means.
Chickens!
You lay an egg right now!
Okay, you know what?
If you don't lay an egg...
If you don't lay...
Oh shit, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
I'm gonna go now.
They were too...
Look...
They called my bluff, guys.
They called my bluff.
What could I do?
They knew I was bluffing.
They knew.
What could I have done?
I can't believe they knew.
You should not be named!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
At this rate, I will rescue...
You know what?
That would be more convenient for me if she does rescue herself.
I would be okay with that.
I'd be like 100% okay with that.
If she wants to rescue herself.
Then I can just go home.
Why the fuck would I...
Why would I keep going?
I'd rather just go home.
Where is this place?
I'd rather go back...
to my home.
Why would I want to be in Europe?
Like what the fuck?
Right now?
Look at what's going on in Europe right now.
Like... taxes, man.
Bacon!
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
By the time you find Ashley, you can use this for retirement funds.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Alright.
Backwards 3.
Is that it?
Is that all the numbers?
All I see is backwards 3.
Is there more stuff over there?
I can't tell.
Is that a symbol over there?
Oh!
That!
Whatever that is.
Anymore?
All this yellow is not very hard to see.
Uh...
Amber Alert!
Sammy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ashley Graham.
Caucasian female.
Last seen.
Resident Evil 4.
Look!
I am trying my best here!
Wait.
There's so many backwards 3.
Which is the right backwards 3?
There's more backwards 3 to this?
How do I piece the backwards 3 together?
What?
Okay, wait.
I'm gonna get on our boat.
Clearly.
This is the second floor.
Well, I can't fucking go through there.
How the fuck do I go to the second floor?
Oh.
Guys, I figured it out.
Guys, I did it.
I figured out how to get to the second floor.
Okay.
Backwards 3 and this line.
Bro, I'm just gonna draw this.
Fuck this.
Bro.
I can't.
I'm too lazy to get a piece of paper.
Okay, chat.
You're gonna help me remember this.
Okay.
Um...
Three people sitting in a group.
Backwards 3 with a little bump.
What's the third one?
Wait.
What's the second button?
What's the second one then?
Okay, this is locked.
Okay.
Okay, we got two.
Three fish kissing.
Wait, that's a great one.
Three fishies kissing.
Um... Backwards 3 with a little bump.
Needs to go see a doc.
Backwards 3 that needs to see a doctor?
Uh...
On the ladder?
Oh!
Tidal waves.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
We are not brute forcing.
Tidal waves.
Backwards 3 that needs to see a doctor.
And then three fish kissing.
Yay!
We did it!
Nice.
Oh, and there's money.
I like money.
Okay, and then we grab that.
Oh my god!
There's the hexagon!
Leon has to hurry.
According to Chris, Clara is hitting on him.
Rodrigo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, nice.
Now we got the key.
Oh hey, and then there's the...
stab!
Nice, we got the ruby.
There you go.
Now I can go through this door for no reason.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Alright, this was definitely much more chill than the other one.
Hahaha!
That was definitely much more chill.
Alright, we go...
Nice!
$100!
Bam!
Alright, we need to go see the fish.
We have all the hexagon pieces now.
Ashley, don't worry.
We're almost done here, Ashley.
Ashley, do not worry!
Leon is almost done exploring!
Look!
Look, he's young!
Okay?
Okay, let's go.
He's young!
And he has to like explore!
He's not gonna be like mid-twenties forever!
Or young twen... I don't know, early twenties?
Hahaha!
Alright, nice.
Now I can do the puzzle!
Okay, how do I do a puzzle?
Okay.
What is this?
Is this like that?
Oh, done.
Okay.
That was easy.
Deprived idol?
What's that for?
What the fuck is that for?
How old is Leon?
Anyway...
I did it!
But what do I do with this?
What do I...
Uh...
Hahaha!
Is that money?
I like money.
Alright, here we go.
We got it!
Yay!
Okay, now!
Now we go back to the merchant!
Oh, is it treasure?
Nice!
Guys, I found this historical...
This historical artifact.
This time the British Museum it.
Hahaha!
It's good to know Leon is just like the British Museum.
Alright, here we go.
Why can't you...
Bro, what the fuck?
There we go.
I was gonna say like...
What the fuck?
Do I have to park it correctly?
Hahaha!
I mean it is zero!
Alright, here we go.
Let's see...
Did I sell it?
I can!
An eerie statue!
Made of gold!
Hello!
Oh my god!
This like...
Clearly an historical artifact made hundreds and thousands of years ago.
Whoop!
Time to sell it!
Hahaha!
You're welcome!
Alright.
Let's see.
We gotta save our game.
Just in case.
Alright.
Shoutout to Night!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Just looked it up.
Leon is 27 in Resident Evil 4.
And British the idol...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
What?
15,000 dollar runies?
Let's fucking go!
It's alright!
If they really want it back...
They'll just buy it.
If they really want back their artifact...
They'll just buy it back!
Hahaha!
They clearly don't care because it wasn't protected that way!
Guys!
That was sarcasm.
Before anybody tries to cancel me for this...
That was a joke!
Before...
Before anyone tries to cancel me!
Hahaha!
Okay.
Let's see.
Um...
Alright.
We gotta go back and place the heads!
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Uhhhh...
Alright.
Time to put the heads in the hands.
They're gonna firmly grasp it.
Oddball!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
The adventures of Indiana Doki.
The quest for more money!
I'm just like Indiana Jones!
But instead of returning the artifacts...
I take it back and sell it.
So like the good one.
The relatable Jones.
Alright.
Church insignia.
This.
What do I do with this?
What the quest item?
I have the church insignia now!
Oh.
Okay.
I had to call.
Hahaha!
Now I should go get Ashley!
Oh my god!
It's Ashley time!
Finally!
After trying to get Ashley!
Now it's Ashley time!
Alright.
How do I get back to the church though?
How?
How do I get there?
Here?
How to get to church?
Hahaha!
Cause I need help!
How do we go back to the church?
Hahaha!
Okay.
Ashley?
Where's the fish?
Guys.
Where's the lunch box?
Blunker fish.
Find from the merchant's area?
Oh wait.
That's how we get back to the church.
The first treasure.
Okay.
But how do we get to the boat house?
Take the boat house.
Oh!
That's the boat house?
There's the fish there?
Okay.
Alright.
We go to get the fish.
We'll do it.
Like my Oshii Mr. Krabs.
It says...
Money?
Hahaha!
Alright.
Here.
Here we go.
Alright.
Let's see.
There he is!
Can I...
Bro!
There he is!
Alright.
He's gonna walk into my spear right here.
Boom!
What the fuck?
What fish is this?
Oh.
There we go.
Nice.
I did it.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I need a...
I'm circling around.
Give me a sec.
Where did the fish go?
Wait.
Where did he go?
Oh.
There he is!
Okay.
Oh.
It's just a bass!
It's too small!
Wait.
How big are these fish supposed to be?
It's just dredge time.
Whoa!
That's a big fish!
Okay.
Now I know!
Now I know how big the fish is supposed to be.
Guys.
I have a size of reference now.
Oh god.
Okay.
Good.
That's good.
I did that so... Okay.
There we go.
Now we know.
Double tap.
Just in case.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be that big.
Just in case.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be that big.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh.
Come on man!
Okay.
We gotta figure...
We gotta... We gotta fucking...
Alright.
There we go.
Big fish.
Alright.
We have to go to the merchant anyway.
Here we go.
I can't believe it.
An hour and twenty minutes.
And now we're progressing the story.
Now.
Now we're progressing.
Alright.
Here we go.
First fish is... What do you mean by that?
What do you mean by the first fish is you?
In what way?
What's your name?
Who said that?
Ooh.
What do you mean by this?
Alright.
Let's sell this fish.
It's only five thousand.
It's a big fish!
Okay.
Here we go.
Damn.
We did it!
Yeah!
We got an explosive friend!
Look.
He made that comment!
I'm just curious what he meant!
I wanna take care of any leftover errands before going this way.
Be ashamed to live the rest of your life wondering what if am I right?
I already did everything.
Oh.
He's like a hint to be like this is.
You won't come back here.
Okay.
I think we're good.
I think we did everything.
I mean we got so many upgrades.
I swear.
I did like ten plus saves just in this one area.
Uhhhhhh.
Is this how we go back?
Is this the door?
Oh wait.
I missed out on some resources.
Okay.
We go through here.
Boop!
Alright.
Here we go.
Up we go!
Alright.
Let's see.
We're missing some resources here.
Alright.
Let's see.
We're missing some resources here.
Where is it though?
It's like here somewhere?
Oh there it is.
Okay.
I found it.
That's good.
We needed that too.
Nice!
We didn't see.
I forgot about this.
Nice!
Money!
Okay.
That means I can put gems in here.
Wait.
Three at the same?
At three at the same.
1.4.
Yes!
Okay.
I got this.
Boop!
Nice!
That is 21,000.
Alright.
We're going back down.
Guys this is important.
Wait.
How do I?
I'm so lost.
Which way?
This way?
Guys this is important!
Hello I'm back!
I'm back!
You thought I was gonna go?
I got some more stuff to sell!
Boop!
Okay.
Now I'm good.
Now I'm done!
Okay.
Now we progress!
This is it!
Progression time!
Now we progress the story!
Wait.
You're saying you craft some fucking shotgun ammo?
We are so lacking in that right now.
Now we progress.
God.
This is so dark sometimes.
Okay.
This is...
This way.
And then we go.
God it's so far!
Where's my quick travel?
Where's my Fastpass?
Oh shit!
Oh!
It's a troll!
It's time to pay the toll!
Oh God.
This is it!
We gotta keep April...
Guys, this is it guys!
This is what the rifle is for!
This is it!
Oh my god.
Oh...
Oh he does!
Oh what?!
Why can't I run from that?!
Oh my god thank god I have so much eggs!
It's egg time!
I have the reload!
Sir please wait!
Please wait!
Yes!
Wooo!
Oh I could have done a quick time event with that.
I'm done.
Wooo!
Nice!
Don't kill him!
No!
Oh god.
I didn't realize I could use it.
Wait what?
Wait is that it?
That's what I'm talking about!
Good boy!
Oh god.
No!
He wants to run!
Give me a sec!
Yes!
Large boy!
Bro what?
That's it?
I told you.
I told you!
Rifle is for bosses only!
This is why I didn't use my rifle!
Let's get to that church.
RIFLE IS FOR BOSSES ONLY!
Where's the good wolf?
Where did the good wolf go?
Oh shit.
Nice loot.
Boop!
Nice.
Alright.
We need more rifle ammo though.
We are actually lacking now.
In the rifle department.
Okay we got...
We gotta like save up for this.
His mission is done.
Thank you.
Finally.
Finally we have the good wolf.
We waited so long for him to show up.
Oh my god there's so much kitchen knives too.
Oh my god I'm raining in fucking ammo.
Jesus Christ.
This is a mess now.
This is actually a mess to look at now.
We can combine this to make the super potions.
Oh my god.
Bro this hurts to look at.
Go into his den.
Oh yeah his little home.
There must be stuff in here right?
Wait is this the...
Wait did I come from here?
No I came from here.
Where is your house?
Is it here?
Yeah this is where you live right?
Six months.
It's teeth have only just come through.
But it shoves everything within it's reach into it's mouth.
It can't walk yet.
But it swallowed a dog whole.
Nine months.
It already towers over me.
But it keeps growing.
The town hall can no longer lock it.
It can no longer contain it.
Ten months.
It keeps growing.
Even after moving to the quarry.
It can devour a whole cow in only three days.
It can swing our largest pig ass as if it were a twig.
One of the men of the village was almost eaten today too.
It's not getting enough food.
Seventeen months.
There are only a few cows left now.
At this rate the whole village will starve.
We summoned help from the castle.
And had them put the beast to sleep with an incantation.
Hopefully it won't wait for a long time.
That sucks man.
You spent all this time.
This is a tiny house.
This is a really tiny house.
That poor fucking troll.
Oh my god.
Wait it even had leftover meat.
How are you starving?
You literally had meat here.
Oh my god.
It's so hard to get food.
Hello troll.
I didn't need to pay the toll.
Is there anything else I missed?
I think I got everything right?
Poor guy.
Dog!
Hello dog.
Thank you for your service.
Here.
Let us cut our palms.
And shake our hands.
So we can be blood brothers.
Hahaha.
What?
It's a blood pack.
He did a good job.
I'm just trying to do a blood pack with him.
Where the fuck do I go?
This way?
Where's my flashlight?
Alright here you go.
Give him an egg.
You cannot pet the dog.
9 out of 10.
I can't believe it.
I can't pet the fucking dog.
9 out of 10.
What's the point?
What the fuck is the point?
You can't pet the dog.
Alright this way.
Okay.
I have so much ammo for my handgun now.
God.
I hope Ashley does never shows up.
Oh god evil dog.
You know what?
Evil dog.
Goodbye evil dog.
Goodbye.
Jesus.
This gun is so strong now.
Alright we gotta go to the church.
It's church time.
You guys have any confessions to make?
Oh wait.
There's a...
Let me go save my game.
I forgot there's like a hole here.
Here right?
Here.
Yeah there's a safe spot here.
Alright.
Save the game first.
Before we do anything.
I don't wanna kill the troll again.
Alright.
Game breaking bug.
Can't pet the...
The dog.
What's the point?
Hahahaha.
I would like to return this game.
Let's see.
Yeah but I can't do anything with that.
It's a locked drawer.
Let's see.
Here we go.
I have a key.
I have the thing.
We're progressing the story.
Nice.
This is a well designed church.
This is where all the villagers money went into.
Hello.
I am...
It's this puzzle.
I know this puzzle.
We have to align this thing.
Look for Ashley in the church.
I got a key.
Wait I can unlock the door.
Okay.
Ashley?
Puzzle time.
Okay.
Wait but what about the other button?
Is there another button?
Oh maybe...
Maybe the...
Oh wait.
Vault.
What the fuck I don't have an arrow.
I don't have a thing there.
Do I need to...
Where do you find the other button?
I don't remember.
Oh hey.
Why are these...
I like how they're all the ammo I don't need.
I don't have any of those guns.
What are you trying to say?
Oh there you go.
There's the blue dial.
Nice.
There it is.
What are you trying to say man?
Okay we're gonna put this here.
God damn it.
I don't have any.
The merch is not near me.
Okay we're gonna figure this out.
We need to...
We need to clean this up.
Okay and then we'll...
Put that...
Okay this is definitely not clean.
Okay.
There we go.
Perfect.
We need like...
One more so I can craft more rifle ammo.
And then we should be good.
And then everything will be okay.
This might not look very pretty.
But everything will be okay soon.
Everything will be okay soon.
Okay.
Bam.
I need to remember how to do this.
Clearly not like...
Like that.
No.
Oh here.
Okay we got that.
And then...
Oh this puzzle is easy.
It's as easy as the fucking...
The other puzzle.
The circles.
There.
For babies.
Nice.
Oh that's so pretty.
Alright Ashley.
We're finally gonna find you.
It's time Ashley.
Alright Ashley.
Ashley?
Oh.
Nice.
Okay now we can craft the rifle.
Okay this feels a lot better.
This looks a little bit better.
This looks a bit better.
Okay guys.
It looks...
It looks less fucked up.
Okay but what if I just put all of this below here.
And I put this here.
And then there.
There you go.
Efficiency.
We're not gonna eat the eggs.
I'm full HP.
There's no point.
There's no point to eat the eggs when you're full HP guys.
I'm trying to make sure I don't...
Oh hey there's Ashley's phone.
Okay.
Okay there's nothing here.
So she's behind this door.
Ashley?
Ashley are you here?
Ashley Graham are you in here?
Oh shit!
It's not a phase Leon!
Come here man.
What?
This isn't a phase Leon.
Oh no it's the second time!
Not a phase
Oh f***!
Guys!
I just need to know guys!
Does it end?
Does the wave end?
Because if it does, I'm just gonna kill all of them.
Oh my god, we finally completed the chapter!
Yay!
It does?
I'm gonna kill all of them.
I'm not gonna steal.
Guys, I have enough ammo to do this, clearly.
It will... everything has an end.
Good.
That's all that matters.
Alright.
It's time.
We have to.
We have too much inventory space.
What do we do?
We kill all of them, Ashley.
We're gonna do it Doki style.
Brute force it until they're all dead.
Guys, I'm such an ugly...
Ugly skin.
It makes me feel less bad.
When she dies... if she dies.
It makes me feel less horrible.
Alright.
Okay, we can get up here.
We go up here and then we kill them all.
Go Ashley.
Go Ashley, go.
Uh, Jesus Christ.
Just throw .
It's an ugly outfit.
Okay, Ashley.
You stay here.
And I'm gonna shoot everything.
Dude...you okay?
Ashley, you stay here.
I'm gonna shoot everything.
Ashley.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Now she's safe.
There we go.
We have so much ammo, we can do this.
Ow!
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Alright, let's just get that out of the way.
Alright, reloading.
Wait, where is he going?
Hello?
I'm over here.
Hello.
Nice.
Is she gonna turn?
Wait, they don't even have loot!
What the fuck?!
They don't even have loot?!
Bro!
This...
They don't even have loot!
It's supposed to be sneaked out.
What's the point?!
Oh my god.
Ashley, I don't wanna look at you.
Oh look, I don't get punished because there was ammo here anyway.
Oh my god.
I thought I could've got free loot!
This is so unfair.
UwUzaporok just killed the not-so-innocent elderly.
Alright, here we go.
I can't get over this outfit.
Damn, it's really something.
Thank you, sweet soul.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Stay there!
Just don't leave!
I can't look at her.
Make it stop.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't keep calling Ashley's outfit ugly.
It's breaking my heart.
No, what about the makeup?
Okay, you stay here.
Um... I can't... No, she follows me forever.
Fuck, okay.
I got baby eagle.
She's right here.
Sure.
I'll try my best.
Can you not just send a helicopter here?
Can you send a helicopter here?
Head for the extraction point.
Jesus Christ, it's all the way...
Okay, we're clearly not gonna...
Well, knowing by this, you're gonna get kidnapped somewhere here.
Alright, Ashley!
I'm gonna make you stay somewhere very close by.
Okay, Ashley?
You are going to... Okay, I'm just gonna fucking...
open this real fast.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay, Ashley.
Your job!
Okay, tight and loose.
Switch between tight...
Ashley, stay close while...
You can... It's gonna be effective when running past enemies.
Okay, switch...
Ashley, hang behind...
Okay, that is...
We'll hang... What the fuck?
Behind Leon while in loose...
This can help her avoid enemies' attack.
Okay.
Ashley, stay close behind while in tight formation.
It's gonna be effective when running past enemies.
Ashley, you... Okay.
How do I make her stay?
Stay.
Where am I?
Spread out.
Okay.
On me.
Just...
Give me some space.
Spread out.
Okay, spread out.
Give me space.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
We're just...
Get behind me.
What is wrong with these people?
I don't know, but I don't think they like that I'm fucking shooting them.
I think that was it.
Oh, that's a lot.
Okay, let me reload.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
This is where things get spicy.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
It's fine.
Thick thighs.
Save lives.
Ashley, and this is why you gotta buff up your thighs.
Oh, Ashley, stay behind me.
Ashley, no.
No, come on, maybe like right now.
Ashley!
I said stay behind me!
That is not tight!
Ok, oh my god what...
Oh, fuck!
This is what eggs are for.
Thanks for...
Okay.
Guys, I have no time to-
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, please I'm reloading.
Are you okay?
Alright, nice.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright.
Get the fuck up.
Okay, we're fine.
Just stay in here, I'm gonna open this drawer.
Okay, we got the- we're gonna save our game now.
We're gonna save- actually, please, afford our love, oh god, where is the stay here command?
I thought- I thought this- I- Ochi Resident Evil 4 had stay here.
This is what all does.
All the eggs were for her.
Thank fucking god for the eggs.
Okay, we're gonna put this here.
Alright.
She is not- She was in the original?!
The original let me say stay here?!
Okay, let's see.
Do I have enough to make more shotgun ammo?
Cause that is what we need right now.
Craft.
Oh, thank god, we had to- Okay.
Okay, there you go, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, she's a rebel now.
Bro, fucking Ashley, man.
Alright.
Stay behind me!
Where?
I hear some noise.
Wait, there's ammo here though.
Time to make some noise.
Wait, what?
Here we go.
Oh, I couldn't run in there in time.
Oh, nice thing guy.
Alright, I need you to die a bit faster so I can take your loot.
Nice gunpowder.
That is good.
Stay behind me, Ashley!
Behind!
Please.
Okay, nice.
The merchant's here.
Oh, thank god.
Thank you for the money.
Oh, you do?
I need- We're gonna do items.
Oh, it's- these are not new items.
I had all of these.
What the fuck do you mean?
You're a liar!
They're the same thing!
Okay, let's see.
We're gonna have to sell our- like- one of our flash grenades.
We have way too much.
We're gonna- We have- We have- wait.
Okay, we're gonna sell the bolts.
Cause we are not running any bolts.
And we are not running submachine gun.
We are not running submachine gun.
We have everything we need!
We have ammo!
We have- We ha- look, we just have too much flashes!
We had too many!
We just had too many, okay?
I just don't have enough space, guys.
We had- we just didn't have a lot of space.
If it was worth it.
Worth the exchange.
Look!
Look how much better my inventory is now.
Chat.
Like, it was a pro- it was turning into a problem.
I was becoming a hoarder.
And that's bad.
Honestly.
Like, it started getting a little too messy, guys.
Like, it started- Okay, here we go.
Like, it was starting to become a really bad, big problem.
Alright, save.
Okay, Ashley, here we go.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I think it's time to get rid of the wild dog that's been roaming out- Which one?
There were so many!
There's so many wild dogs!
Which one?
Which one are they talking about?
There's like, so many!
Don't tell me they're fucking bigger than before.
The super duper dog.
Oh no.
I have Ashley here!
I mean, you can if you don't stay with the merchant.
Do I need to reload my gun?
No, I don't.
Okay, I just have to be sure.
Hahaha.
Dan, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Why does everyone hate the SMG?
It's a great gun.
Well, the pistol is just faster.
I just have to hit the headshot.
Which I totally do, because I'm a gamer.
I just think the pistol is just faster.
I missed the stay here command.
Okay, is there an end?
Guys, I need to know!
Is there an end to these guys?
Hahaha.
Oh, did I miss the bearer?
Oh, there it is.
Like, right in front of me.
Yes?
Okay, it's time.
It's time, guys.
There is an end.
Every time there's an end, I fight.
I fight.
If there's an end.
Oh fuck, okay.
Oh my god!
Ashley, no!
Stay behind!
Hahaha.
Ashley!
I said tight!
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, nice.
We can guard the window.
Guys, we'll just guard the window.
Nice.
We'll just guard the window.
Oh my god!
Okay, we're fucking throwing this.
Son of a bitch.
Okay.
Easy.
Guys, and that is how you guard the window.
Guys, the window.
The window is the strat!
They always have to come to the window!
There we go.
Just guard the window!
Nice.
The power of the window!
There you go.
Is that everybody?
There... okay.
Now that's not cool, man.
Okay, I know you're gonna pop up now.
Alright, nice.
Are you dead?
I can't tell the window!
The window is so dark!
Window!
Okay, Ashley, this is why...
This is why I have the cheese.
It's because of you.
Ashley, this is your fault.
I have the cheese even harder because of you.
Are they done?
Okay, are they all dead?
I killed a lot.
Alright, no, I don't have a window anymore if I have to do this.
The window MVP.
Oh my god.
Definitely gonna catch a cold.
Ashley, shut the fuck up.
I have to...
You're the... You're a problem.
You're a problem right now.
Okay, let's see.
Oh my god.
Oh, my inventory is so empty now.
Okay, let's see...
Alright...
Oh, we can finally get this loot.
Ashley!
Are they all dead?
Have we windowed enough?
No, I hear one guy.
I hear him, lurking.
I'm freaking...
Alright, there you go.
Wait, what the fuck?
Where is he going?
Does he know I'm here?
Does this man know I'm here?
I don't know if he knows.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Alright.
No, I don't think he still knows, guys.
It's okay.
We can kill him all the way here.
He still doesn't know.
He's walking back.
Guys, I don't think he knows.
He's walking backwards.
We're fine.
Actually, cover your ears.
I think he can make this shot.
Okay.
It was a waste of my ammo.
It should be this, right?
Wait, where is the... Oh no, it's the door behind us.
Alright.
It's right here.
Nice.
Ashley, come over here.
I need this loot.
This is exactly why I needed you here.
This is the most imp...
This is your purpose.
This is your entire purpose.
To open that one door for me.
Come on, Ashley.
Nice.
Thank you.
I've always wanted to be in this room.
Alright, now you can leave.
Nice.
What is this?
The Elegant Vangle!
Oh my god!
Okay.
I can put the two yellow stones in!
Oh my god, how much money is it?
22,000.
Ashley, good job, girl.
You were worth it.
You were worth babysitting.
Get paid $5 to babysit.
Get $22,000 back.
Profit.
Alright.
We gotta kill that one guy over here, right?
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm gonna make sure all the people here are dead before I do any of this.
Like, I hear noises.
I don't know if it's coming from...
Like, where is that coming from?
Inside?
Is there somebody inside?
I hear the...
I'm like, fucking, up-bees.
Or, up-bees.
Up-bees.
Where is that coming from?
Who's calling for up-bees right now?
Okay, we go up.
Who wants up-bees?
You hear that?
They keep calling for up-bees!
Him, right?
Is it this guy?
Oh, it's him!
He wanted up-bees!
I fucking knew it!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck!
No!
Okay.
Alright.
He fucking scared me.
Alright, we got him.
It's fine.
We still have the eggs.
Actually, I don't even need a heal.
There we go, we're fine.
From 80 bullets to 20.
20 bullets.
It was worth it.
I wonder if I should open...
I feel like they'd be empty because I looted this area already.
Yeah?
Yeah, I looted this.
Alright, here we go.
They're all dead.
We did it.
Mayor's house before you progress?
Where's the mayor's house?
Here?
Guys, I don't know where the fucking mayor lives.
Like...
Oh, here!
Okay, but what do I get?
Guys, but what do I get though?
You gotta convince me here.
How much money?
A jewel?
Okay.
Oh, I have Ashley though.
Guys, but what if I die?
Hi!
I have to deal with Ashley!
Like...
Okay, now we're talking business.
Okay.
Guys!
I have to deal with Ashley though!
It's worth the risk.
It's worth the Ashley risk?
Okay, I'm gonna go save my game then.
Guys, I'm gonna go save my game.
There's no way.
Ashley, you're coming with me.
We're saving our game.
I fucking killed so many people with the window.
Ashley, you are not worth it, girl.
You're absolutely not worth it.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, where did Ashley go?
Oh, there she is.
Okay.
Alright.
Please, stay behind me, Ashley.
Okay, you know what?
You guys were right.
I miss OG Ashley.
This Ashley fucking sucks.
Like...
This Ashley is terrible.
At least OG Ashley...
If I tell her to stay, she stays.
This Ashley is terrible.
This Ashley does not stay.
This Ashley does not know the concept of please stand back.
I have a gun.
Okay.
It should be this way.
Back we go.
Can I trade for OG Ashley?
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna bring my shotgun.
Just in case we see the super dog.
Just in case super dog decides to show up.
Super dog?
We all wanna go home, Ashley.
But here we are.
Super dog.
Where are you?
Where's super dog?
I don't like that.
It started making the ambience noise.
Super dog?
Is super dog here?
Super dog.
Why is there...
creepy ambience?
Where's that treasure?
Is that...
Oh, the savage mud.
Okay.
Super dog is here.
Alright, super dog.
Super dog is apparently here now.
Is the super dog in the room with us?
Super dog?
Where are you?
Is the treasure like...
upstairs?
Cause I don't remember.
Super dog?
Alright, time to save.
Okay.
Super dog, I have a shotgun!
I have a treat for you!
Hello?
Where's super dog?
I forgot where the treasure is.
Oh, it's a collapsible ladder!
This is where super dog is!
Got it.
Alright, here you go.
Alright, nice.
I'm up.
It's called treasure.
Okay.
All the men cheered...
And then everyone clapped.
All the men...
All the men cheered when they heard the boat.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
This is really fun!
Alright, let's go up hill.
Oh, what?
This is great.
Oh, I like it.
It's amazing.
This is the treasure.
I'm really glad that you're here.
I love having you here.
What about you guys?
It's a pleasure.
Nice.
Okay.
I don't know if a fucking guy came from a castle and injected you with something.
I don't know.
Do you trust that?
And that really be trusted.
Oh, that's him!
Is that a priest?
What is that?
Watch over the village in my stead and me smiles always find you in photographs.
A little bit.
Yes, he shouldn't.
Oh hey, there's a...
Nice.
Alright, reload.
Okay, what's this photo?
Is this lore?
The long awaited ironworks.
Oh, this is lore.
Money.
Did I miss anything?
Oh, there's more lore.
The Elrond's house.
You trusted the village to me today.
You told me I could learn my duties as I go.
I'll start by keeping a record of the village.
There's so many words I cannot write, but the Elder encouraged me.
I will do my best.
There is a young boy who lives in the cabin by the lake with his grandfather.
It seems that his mother was called to heaven upon his birth.
His grandfather doesn't talk much, but the lad is very bright and spirited.
He told me a story about a knight who rides a donkey again today.
The boy's grandfather told me a story about a knight who rides a donkey again today.
The boy worries terribly about him and there are murmurs of madness among the villagers.
As I took my leave, the old man pulled me aside and said, If anything happens, you know what to do.
I can only nod in response.
It was a terrible night.
Everyone stood around the cabin and watched as it burned to the ground.
The boy looked on without saying a word.
Even as dawn broke, he didn't move a muscle.
The next day, he was gone.
And then everyone clapped.
I missed a box over there?
Okay, let me check where it is.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Got an anti-camera.
What the fuck do I do with that?
Oh, this is the boy and his family.
That's him.
Wait, is that gonna be me?
Is that gonna be the short guy in the...
In the later on?
Did he grow up to be evil?
Did you grow up to be evil, little boy?
Alright.
Apparently you have to be spread out right now because of the wolf.
Alright, what do we got here?
There's the evil wolf.
I'm gonna say that and then the evil wolf is gonna fucking come out and like...
bite me or some shit.
Zondervan, you 1% seem the type to skip the lore.
What the heck is happening?
What do you mean?
I always read the lore!
It's the lore!
It's the lore pause!
The lore always gives us the fucking pauses!
It's the safe space!
Okay, guys.
Where's the evil dog?
Where's super dog?
Like, this is very important.
Where the fuck is super dog?
The lore breaks?
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna save our game just in case.
Where outside?
The other outside?
This outside?
Is super dog on this side?
Super dog.
Super dog, are you here?
Super dog!
Oh, I hear him.
I hear super dog.
He's on the other side!
What the fuck?
He's on the other side?
Super dog's on the other side.
When did he get there?
I heard him.
He barked.
Super dog died.
But it wasn't like the scary bark.
He just went...
Wait, I missed the treasure.
Okay, guys.
Where's the treasure again?
I already forgot.
I forgot.
Is that on the first floor or the second floor?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, I got it.
I know I missed something here.
Super dog!
Where are you?
There you are!
Get over here!
Open the door!
Wait, can I just shoot you from here?
Super dog!
Come back!
Where did you go?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Hehehe.
Where are you?
Super dog?
BANG!
This is super duper dog!
Oh my god, super duper dog can dodge.
Super duper dog can dodge!
What the fuck is wrong with this dog?
I said goodbye!
What do you mean?
What is wrong with SuperDuperDog?
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
He said no.
I should have used the sniper jab.
Oh my god.
That shit was scary.
He really was the SuperDog.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know how I lived there.
She screamed Leon.
I was like, what?
Yeah, I did.
I definitely did.
There's no SuperDog in Ba Sing Se.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jesus Christ.
There's nothing worth it.
Okay, we're gonna sell that.
Oh wait, no, I can sell these two.
Okay.
Anti-camera, we got that.
Nice.
Okay.
Is it worth buying the rocket launcher or nah?
Is it worth it?
Is it worth it, guys?
Or nah?
Nah?
Okay.
No, okay.
Nah.
Okay.
Apparently, some people are like, no, and some people are like, nah.
Rocket launcher...
But I have... I have my rifle!
My rifle though!
Okay, we'll trade for the mask and then we can sell.
Do I have enough though for it?
It is... Is it circle?
Round.
Okay, I don't have enough round stuff for that.
Okay.
We're gonna find more jewels later.
Alright.
Man.
Luke, I almost missed out on... Oh wait, there's more money!
I can sell more stuff.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now...
Now we save again.
Guys, don't worry.
We will... We will get to another...
I swear, we will get to another chapter.
Guys, don't worry.
We will get to another chapter soon.
Guys, do not worry.
Did you max out?
I'm pretty sure I maxed it out.
Let's check.
Yeah, everything's maxed... Everything that matters maxed out.
I might as well max out the shock.
Nah!
Will I be finding a better shotgun soon?
Are we gonna...
get a better shotgun soon or should we...
just...
Yeah?
When what chapter?
Yes, very soon?
Okay.
Alright, I won't upgrade it.
I don't want to waste money then.
I'll just upgrade the knife.
Like, might as well.
I'm gonna fix the knife.
Alright, there we go.
As long as we max out the knife, it's fine.
I don't need the better rate of fire.
Honestly.
The rate of fire is like...
Um...
I like... Someone's like, it's next chapter, so not soon.
That's true.
True!
That is so true.
It's not gonna be soon.
Alright, here we go.
We're gonna finally go up.
Ah, fuck.
It's this way.
Alright, let's go.
How do we get up top again?
Oh, ladder.
Here we go.
I remember I... I like, ran for this one.
I didn't kill everybody.
Hahaha!
Don't leave me!
This time I killed everyone.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
I've learned.
Hahaha!
Alright, here we go.
Is there more people?
Ah, there's more people.
Okay, that's fine.
We have ammo here.
Where are they?
Oh, you wanna dodge?
Don't worry.
I... Oh.
Oh.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Kick!
Nice.
Okay, sap!
No.
No!
I couldn't get the sap!
Ashley!
I'm so sorry!
I couldn't get the sap in time!
No, my shotgun.
Oh, my God.
I don't know what happened!
The sap didn't show up!
Hahaha!
What the fuck happened?
My shotgun ammo!
Oh, my shotgun ammo!
No!
A beautiful shotgun ammo.
What the fuck is that?
Is that the cow?
That's the strongman!
This is what the rifle is for.
Nice.
He's dead.
Alright.
There we go.
I mean, the cows are still alive.
Good for them.
The cows are still fucking tanking it.
Okay, we're gonna be living in poverty soon.
Remember when we had like 80 at...
How?
How the fuck?
That was point blank.
Guys, remember when we had 80 bullets?
I'll remember.
How?
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Please.
Please give me a chance to make it.
Okay, there you go.
Please.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Thank god.
Everything is fine.
I have the key!
Money!
Oh, sorry.
Did I stab you?
Wait, can I actually hurt her?
Holy shit.
We are so fucking poverty right now.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Maybe...
No.
Okay.
We are so fucking poor.
Alright.
I need to stop shooting.
We are so poor.
I remember when we used to rule the world.
Hello, piggy.
Hello, cow.
There's like loot here somewhere.
Oh, it is.
Hey, look.
I know.
No!
I fucking forgot about this!
What the?
I couldn't see!
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
It was so dark, guys.
I couldn't see.
It was so dark.
I couldn't see!
How was I supposed to know?
Well.
This is so much fun.
Okay, we gotta save our game.
Nice, alright.
Alright, Ashley, it's time.
We're a little bit in the poverty line right now, but it's okay.
Everything will be okay.
You... you getting hurt?
Are you fucking... are you fucking kidding me?!
You fu-
What's gonna happen?
The cow is gonna fucking run into her again, right?
Are you fucking- it's a cow!
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Ashley, please.
Ashley.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god.
That- fucking damn it, Ashley.
I can't- I can't deal with you, man.
Okay, let's see.
Do you have- can I not buy ammo from you?
This is not fair!
I should be allowed to purchase ammo from you!
Like...
Cause of death, cow.
Okay, is there anything else?
I think I've done everything.
I can.
Yeah, it's all over.
It's okay.
Alright, we're gonna go in.
We're gonna be like below the poverty line.
But like...
God, I hope the president pays well.
I hope he doesn't just give me a medal.
Oh shit, bro!
Bro!
Major, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wonderful, great entertainment like every time.
Thank you!
I'm glad you've been enjoying it!
Bro, I don't want the medal of honor, Mr. President.
Just give me a hundred grand.
I wonder if it's legal to sell your medal of honor from the president.
Hello, Luis.
Now then.
Who are you?
And what are you doing here?
Damn.
Very good questions, Luis.
You like, copied on him.
Hide, now.
In that case...
Here, help me.
Ashley, quick!
Over here.
Yeah, but you don't want to pawn shop it.
You want to put it online to sell.
Cause the pawn shop will always rip you off.
If I ever get a medal of honor, make sure to look at eBay.
Hahaha!
Look at eBay.
And waifu.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Alright.
Use.
Where the fuck do I...
Okay, nice.
Okay.
This is it.
Boom.
Oh shit!
Where did you come from?
Bam!
Oh shit.
Cut!
Oh god.
It's the window time.
It's window time!
Oh god.
Reloading!
Yes!
Give me ammo!
Shoot him!
Oh god.
This is it!
Need time!
Okay.
Now I have to fucking shortcut this.
Oh, why did I sell?
Why did I sell?
Why?
Nice throw it.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
Why did I sell my flash?
Wait.
I got loot here.
Go, Louis!
Go!
I'm just grabbing some ammo!
Boom!
Oh, I'm so lucky.
Haha!
Oh shit, that's not what I wanted.
Oh god.
I need to reload.
I need to re- Louis!
That's a fucking barrel!
Okay.
That's okay.
Kick!
Oh, not good.
Not good.
Not good!
Can Louis give me ammo for this?
No, it's only handguns only.
It's handguns only apparently!
Oh god, more wooden planks, nice.
It's okay, I'm gonna reinforce this!
Nice.
Alright.
Now he can only go one way.
Where did he come from?!
Okay.
Oh!
Shit!
Yes!
Oh no, he has ladder!
Where are you gonna come from?!
The stairs?!
Oh shit, okay.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm going up.
Leon, why?
Why did you pause?!
AHHHHH!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry, Ulysses!
Oh shit!
Okay, this is time for heal time.
This is good time for heal time.
This is...
Oh, it's time!
Oh shit!
It's time!
I don't remember my shortcut!
I don't remember my shortcut bindings!
Ah, this is it!
Uh!
Fuck!
Okay, let me....
I'm trying!
Equip!
Boom!
If you die it's not my fault.
Okay.
There you go.
It's fine.
The eggs!
This is why we have the eggs!
It's daytime!
If you die, it's not my fault!
Okay.
It's fine.
Nice!
There ya go.
Please!
Oh, please!
Oh, God.
Yes, I am very busy.
What the fuck!
He one-shots me!
Where's my egg?
Bros, give me the ammo!
Bro, give me the ammo!
Luis, if you die, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry if you die.
Oh, God.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Oh, thank you!
Holy shit!
Ashley, door saved me!
The moment I saw the axe come straight to me.
I was like, this is the moment!
The fuck!
Holy shit!
Ashley, it was good timing!
Good timing!
The clutch!
Finally, Ashley did something useful.
Bro, where you go?
Oh, cause they injected her with stuff.
I was saved by the plot.
The moment I saw the axe, I knew.
The cough.
The blood.
It's caused by something called the...
Plaga.
The Plaga?
You saw those people, right?
But you have the same thing inside you.
The same thing that made them like that.
Wait, we're gonna turn like them?
The guys which are experiencing these symptoms.
They're only the beginning.
I don't wanna become like them.
You are, well...
Lucky.
Wait, how so?
You see, at this early stage, the parasite, the Plaga.
It is possible to remove it.
With the surgical procedure.
And all you need is some know-how.
And oh yeah, the right equipment.
Wait, do you know how?
No worries.
See, I have a kitchen knife.
I have a kitchen knife.
But you're going to have to trust me.
Would this help?
Great, we're partners then.
Hey, why are you...
Thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Because it makes me feel better.
Let's leave it at that.
We'll contact you later.
Wait, what?
He's just gonna leave?
He's just gonna leave me like that?
Oh my god, we've made it to another chapter guys.
We're doing it.
We're fucking...
I'm gonna save it right here.
We're fucking doing it.
We actually made it to another chapter.
Goodbye, Lewis.
Goodbye.
Wait, we're gonna see more?
I saw him leave.
Hey.
Ada?
I do.
The kind you like.
Now where's the amber?
Fortunately, it's not on me at the moment.
And you really should be telling me.
What a good job I did.
Busted my ass and managed to hide it right before I got caught.
Which...
Is why I'm still alive.
I think she's just making him cry then.
I'm gonna go get the amber.
No amber, no protection, Lewis.
Such a stickler for details, huh, Ada?
Okay then.
I'll go get each now.
How about that?
And I do have something else I need to get too.
What?
What is it?
Can I not go back?
That sucks.
There was so much loot over there.
I don't like this.
The chopper can't make its approach.
No!
Negative.
Too dangerous.
We're gonna get out of here and find someplace safe.
I'm sorry.
I wish I could do more to help.
Bro, you barely helped at all.
We could swim home if we have to.
Condor One, out.
We could take the boat.
We take the boat.
Look at all this loot!
No!
It's just staring at me!
So fucked up.
What's gonna happen to me?
Right now.
Gone forever.
Let's just focus on getting out of here.
Goodbye loot.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
But I do have all these kitchen knives.
Okay, I'm gonna make...
I'm gonna save this.
I need to use my kitchen knives.
Not gonna lie.
Do I have enough?
No, I need two more.
I need to save up.
See, look.
All those grenades were worth it in the end.
Guys, they were all worth it.
God, there is way too many kitchen knives.
What am I gonna do with all these kitchen knives, man?
My inventory is finally loaded.
I'm looking clean.
All that hoarding.
Gone from one fucking chapter.
What is this?
This is bullshit.
What's the point of having money if I can't buy ammo?
What's the point?
Why are you giving me more money?
Give me ammo!
You ever seen those nasty guns?
Guys with the tentacles on their head?
Not only are they dangerous, but they are a pain to kill.
They do have a weakness though.
They absolutely hate bright lights like the sun.
That's why you won't see them during...
Oh, thank you.
Wow.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Really?
The riot gun.
Oh shit, is this a better shotgun?
Wait, is this the better shotgun?
Okay, I'm gonna sell my old shotgun then.
Which one?
I almost sold the rifle.
This is the bad one, right?
Yeah.
This is the...
Okay, I'm gonna sell the old shotgun.
I don't need you anymore.
Alright, bye.
Riot gun.
Okay, yeah.
I'm done playing with you.
Alright, here you go.
Uh, then we can...
Upgrade our good shotgun.
Okay.
Nice.
And then... power.
That's all we need.
We just need a full power.
And then...
I don't really need anything else other than that.
Honestly.
Everything else is a waste of money.
Ooh!
The stock!
Wait, this is good!
Okay, we're gonna need...
We're gonna need this.
And then...
I'm gonna grab more gunpowder at this rate.
I'm fucking desperate.
I'm so desperate.
Okay, we're gonna put...
Uh... put this here.
And then here.
Alright, there we go.
Alright.
Good.
We're good.
Yes.
Alright, here we go.
Should be good now.
And then we can make more ammo for the fucking shotgun!
Okay, shotgun shells.
We always need ammo for a shotgun.
Alright.
We should be good now.
Boop!
Because they gave me rifle!
They always give me rifle ammo.
They know what I want.
Oh, there's boxes here.
Thank god it's... Thank god it's marked yellow.
I'm gonna save.
Because I don't want to do that again.
I don't want to do that again.
So I'm gonna save just in case.
Alright.
That's true.
I should be good to go.
Here we go!
Uh... Oh, I missed out.
Wait, what?
How is there ammo that I missed out?
I smashed everything.
What the fuck?
Did I not press the F key?
Where the fuck is that one fucking resource?
Oh, it's here!
Oh, it's on the box!
Here we go.
Nice.
I'm gonna go to the elevator.
It's okay.
I am wil...
Oh.
Quietly?
Okay.
Wait.
Guys.
Does this wave end?
Yes?
Okay.
They...
Oh.
Alright.
We're not doing it quietly.
Yes, but don't do it.
What?
What do you mean?
Why not?
But like...
But I can just kill everybody.
It's more fun.
Yes, but there is a lot.
There can't be that many.
Like...
There is always an end.
Guys.
There's no way.
There's always an end.
Oh, is he turning?
Bro, why is he turning in the middle of this?
That's not fair.
Actually, you're like...
You're like being seen by everything.
Bro, I...
Oh, he got on the bear trap.
There's traps here?
Fuck.
Okay.
I was not expecting the traps.
What?
How?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm not gonna die.
We...
Okay.
Guys, this is bad.
Guys, it's okay.
I have one more.
No.
No warning.
Actually, I don't know.
You know this.
But there's never a warning.
But we have the stock.
Okay.
Look.
It was worth it.
Guys, it was worth it.
Wait.
There's more?
Oh, it's because of the fine lady.
Alright.
Nice.
We're fine.
She has to look up, right?
There you go.
See?
Everything is fine.
We got our ammo back.
Stealth?
I told you we don't need it.
Boom!
That one grenade saved our fucking lives.
There you go.
Thank God for that one grenade that I have.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go back and save.
We're gonna...
We're gonna go back and save.
We... We're...
We're gonna do that again.
Welcome.
What can I...
But like, guys, I don't wanna do that again though.
That's the thing.
What a pleasant travel.
What if Ashley just dies?
Also, Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I can't trust Ashley.
What if she dies?
Chat.
You're gonna be responsible if she just dies.
And I have to do all of that again.
Oh, I forgot to repair the knife.
Sorry, we're going back.
Sorry, Ashley.
We're going back.
What if she doesn't?
Well, that's not the risk I'm gonna take!
It's not even 50-50!
There's more of a chance that she's just gonna fucking die!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
It's so weak.
It's the president's daughter.
It doesn't matter how weak she is.
She's the president's daughter.
Okay, I cannot protect stupid.
I can delay it, but I can't protect it.
What the fuck?
Does Ashley burn?
She doesn't burn.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
She doesn't burn.
That's like...
That's fine.
Alright, nice.
Did she turn?
Well, if she turns, she can't fucking...
do the thing.
Oh, she is turning.
Are you serious?!
I didn't...
Like, what is she gonna do?
Is she gonna drop down?
Yeah, she can't do anything!
Okay, but she's annoying me.
So I'm just gonna kill her.
She is annoying, though.
There you go.
Nice.
God, more money that I don't need.
I need fucking loot, not money.
Thank you.
That's what I need.
Alright.
I thought you guys said like...
It's better if it's like stealth.
That was like not even that many people.
I think maybe it's the...
This is where I should stealth.
If there's people here.
Actually, no.
I don't need to stealth this.
Wait, am I missing loot behind me?
I'm not.
Oh, wait.
I am.
Wait a minute.
I am missing loot.
Sorry, Ashley.
This is important.
Why did I come back here?
Why the fuck did I come back?
Oh, hey.
Nice.
We needed that.
We needed a circular thing.
Okay.
Up we go.
Boop.
Nice.
Rifle ammo.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
That's fine.
Where are all these bear traps coming from?
Where are they all coming from?!
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
It just keeps happening.
Period.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, there is loot here.
How do I get up here?
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck?
Bro, okay.
Don't announce your...
Oh shit!
There we go.
Alright, that's fine.
That is fine.
Do I have another egg?
I do not have another egg.
Okay, we need a yellow herb.
We are... okay.
I think this... it'll be fine.
I can take this.
We don't need to worry.
We'll find... we'll find...
a yellow herb sooner or later.
That's the risk I'm willing...
Okay, maybe not.
The way you're looking at me, Ashley, I don't know if that is the risk I'm willing to take.
I have so many sprays.
This is fine.
I realize that should not be a risk.
I should take.
Like, thinking about it.
That's not a great idea.
Bro, I haven't even fought like Adam Sandler yet.
Where did I go?
Oh, it's this way.
Like, I haven't fought Adam Sandler and I don't know if I'll have the resources for this now.
Because I'm fighting everybody.
Yeah, I don't like that.
It sure is.
Why did you have to...
say that, Leon?
Why?
Never say it's quiet.
It's never a good sign.
Okay.
We gotta go this way.
Welcome, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh!
Okay.
We can stealth this.
Right?
Maybe I'll, like, stab one correctly.
Does he see me?
Oh!
Guys, I thought he didn't see me!
How was I supposed to know?
I don't know!
There was a...
He could have not seen me.
There could have been a possibility.
Out of the way!
It could have been possible.
I just wanted to... No!
I just wanted to test out my theory.
I mean...
Yellow herb!
I should have risked it.
I should have fucking risked it.
I should have risked it, man.
All I'm saying is that MatPat graduated.
So, like, we need somebody to test theories out.
And I was gonna take that risk.
Who else would have done it if it wasn't for me?
Who else?
Okay.
Nice.
So true.
Alright.
Oof!
Nice.
Money!
Order?
Stay inside!
Go into this locker!
Okay.
Oh my god!
This is great!
I don't have to give a shit about you anymore.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Thank you!
You've given me the one thing I could ever ask for.
No, Ashley.
Just live in there for now.
I'll be back after I finish the game, Ashley.
Don't worry.
I'll come back for you.
I promise.
Haha.
I definitely promise.
I just leave her there?
Like, does it really matter?
Guys!
What?
She opened the lock?
Did you open the lock?
Oh no, that's the door.
I was gonna say, Ashley, what did I tell you about not opening that locker?
No, of course not.
I would never leave her.
Okay.
I need to...
Just leave me alone.
I'm just making sure I got all the loot.
There's suspiciously a lot of loot.
I feel like...
Is this gonna be another boss fight?
I feel like I have to run around and shoot people.
I don't know.
This is...
Yeah, this is definitely a run around shooting people.
There is way too many fucking ammo around me.
This is way too suspicious.
Why is there so much ammo?
How do I get to that area?
To here?
There it is.
It's an arena of some kind.
Yeah.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Be right back, guys.
There's no way anybody's gonna attack me.
I'm gonna...
I cannot risk it.
The game might be like, Why is she standing there for so long?
What if we like fucking throw some monsters at her?
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Be right back.
Alright, guys.
I'm back.
Ellen and Luca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm back.
Alright, here we go.
Time to fight something.
Wait, this is not it.
Sorry, I already ran the wrong way.
Where am I?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
Time...
Am I going the right way?
Wait.
Where am I?
Time to fight something.
Here we go.
Alright.
Oh.
That's awkward.
Wait.
That is a little awkward.
Who is that?
Wait a minute.
How?
Where?
Is Lu here?
Um...
Oh no.
Okay, we'll figure this out.
Get in the warehouse.
There's a warehouse?
This?
Is that a house?
There's no doors.
Oh no.
How am I already lost?
Okay.
Oh!
It's here.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Where are my yellow paint?
Where's the yellow paint?
How am I supposed to know anything?
Oh, here!
Oh my god!
There was a door here this entire time?
Can't believe it.
There was a door here this entire time.
Wait, there's the first aid spray.
It's like I never lost it.
I definitely did not notice that.
Let's see.
Oh, there's the cra- Oh!
Chainsaw!
Oh shit!
Does she die?
Oh fuck!
Two chainsaw women?
Why did mom let you have two?
Sorry.
I didn't realize it was yours.
I am flattered.
What the fuck?
Why did mom let you have two?
Oh god.
What the fuck?
Oh!
I knew it!
Oh, thank you for opening that door!
Now I know why Ashley is gone!
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Wait, I hear people behind me.
That's not good.
I don't like it when I hear people behind me.
Oh god.
Oh, I don't like it when there's two chainsaw women!
It's not hot!
Hahaha!
Sometimes two is too many!
It's just, what do you do?
Hahaha!
There's too much going on!
There's just too much going on!
It's just too overwhelming!
Where are they?
Where did chainsaw women go?
Bro, what the fuck man?
What the fuck?
I can just keep going backwards.
Like!
Alright, we're just gonna um...
Me feed... I know my back is clear.
That's what I...
Do I have nades?
Oh, I did!
Bro, I didn't even know I had nades!
Wait, what?
Are they...
Did they just walk away?
Where are they?
They just walked away.
Hahaha!
Hello?
Where did they go?
What?
They gave up?
Oh, thank god!
Hahaha!
Like, where did they go?
Haha!
Like, they all just disappeared!
Alright, let's just get rid of him.
Do they drop anything?
Oh, thank god they do!
Okay, it's worth killing them.
I just need to know where chainsaw women... where the chainsaw women go.
Where are they?
Oh!
Don't break down!
Hahaha!
Holy shit!
Ask and ye shall receive!
Alright, there we go.
Whoa, shit!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Melee!
Oh my god.
He's still alive.
There you go.
Yeah, but I got chainsaw women!
Do they actually keep coming?
Wait.
Do they actually?
Do they...
Hahaha!
Is this infinite?
The most important question!
Hahaha!
Alright.
Goodbye.
Oh, thank god there's always an end.
Oh, thank god!
There's always an end, guys!
There's always an end!
Don't worry!
Oh my god.
Chop, chop, chop!
Nooooo!
Hahaha!
It makes me happy.
What the fuck?
Okay!
It doesn't chop him, but it chops you.
That's five.
Where's he gonna... It's okay.
There's ammo right there.
That's five.
Thank god there's always an end.
Thank fucking god.
Hahaha!
Ashley?!
Who told you to get out of the locker?
Who told you?
Cause it's not me.
I know for sure it was not me.
Ashley, get back in that locker.
Ashley.
Get back.
Hahaha!
Go back into that locker.
Leon did not say get out.
Hahaha!
Go back in here.
I know there was a locker here.
Ashley, get... Oh my god.
No!
I can't keep you here forever?
Nooooo!
Ashley, why do you do this?
Do you hate me, Ashley?
Hahaha!
Ashley, I only had one simple request and it's for you to live in that locker until I was done.
Do you hate me, Ashley?
Ashley, I'm not gaslighting you.
Do you just hate me?
Hahaha!
Alright.
Here we go.
No, I'm... I'm okay.
The locker is your home now, Ashley.
Never leave.
Seems this isn't your first time running from creeps.
Bro, what?
Bro!
Leon!
Hahaha!
Bro, what the fuck, Leon?
That is inappropriate!
I wonder if I can craft more rifle.
Okay, I need two more.
I feel like I definitely need more rifle.
Okay.
Let me put some of this away.
And then...
Oh wait, I'm gonna put this here, actually.
Yeah.
This is like a mess again.
But that's okay.
Alright, nice.
Map updated.
Here we go.
Gotta make sure everything is reloaded.
Right.
Jesus Christ, the objective is all the way there.
Oh my god.
I'd be like...
And then I'd have to go...
Okay, that is a lot of walking.
And a lot of shooting.
Oh.
I'm gonna go back in here.
Bro, get that loot.
God, I don't need more money!
I can't buy anything!
Please!
Please.
I can't even buy anything, so there's no point.
Okay.
Drop down.
No, I'm not autosorting.
I'm not!
I'm not gonna become an iPad kid!
I can Tetris!
I don't need a computer to Tetris for me!
Okay, let's see.
Yeah, we got ammo.
How much ammo do we have?
Yeah, I think we need more rifle ammo.
Let me combine these herbs together.
Craft rifle ammo.
Okay, there you go.
This is a little better now.
Yeah, this is...
Oh my gosh, this is good.
Alright.
Here we go.
I know!
AI has evolved so much!
Okay.
But I have the Doki way.
Whoa!
Adam Sandler?!
Adam Sandler!
Think about your Netflix deals!
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh no, not more.
Bro,
what?
Bro, what fucking protein do you have?
Can he die?!
Oh, flee!
Okay, he cannot die.
We just run.
Guys.
He can't die.
Don't worry!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Go away, Ashley!
Ah!
Bro!
Ashley, just run!
This way.
Ashley, please!
We need to go!
Oh my god!
He can't die!
Bro, this is...
The power of religion.
We did it.
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
Your god can't save you.
Tell your god to make you fly.
Yeah.
Guys, welcome!
Thank you for the one gift!
Thank you!
Oh, thank god.
Okay, we did it.
The power of the bible.
You just gotta believe.
Doki.
Oh, thank god.
There he is.
God, please!
Where is the ammo?
Oh, thank god.
Okay, there we go.
There's the ammo.
Why not trees?
Welcome!
You got a selection of good things on sale.
Okay, a key... Oh, did I use up everything?
Wait, I think that key is like finished, right?
Yeah.
I can sell this now.
Welcome!
And then...
This doesn't have any holes in it, so...
Yeah, it doesn't.
Alright, so we're good here.
And...
Oh, I can do like a combo... Oh, wait!
I can do a combo for this!
Alright, let's do a combo first.
Uh, 7000.
Obviously, we'll do the chalice.
Because that one has the best one.
Alright, wait.
Oh.
Wait, I can do three, right?
333?
Three is the best?
Three... Yeah, three gemstones.
Yes, okay.
Boop.
Nice.
My shiny chalice is complete now.
And then we'll...
This is the three different colors.
Yay!
Hey!
Beautiful!
Alright, sell time.
Sell, sell, sell...
Sell, sell...
Oh my god!
Guys, don't talk to me anymore.
What is...
Guys...
Talk to me when you have the chalice.
I'm in the next tax bracket.
That cash in your pocket for your life.
Okay.
I did it.
I made it to the next tax bracket.
Let's go!
A well-tuned weapon can make up for a lack of skill, friend.
Damn, money really does change people.
Okay, let's see.
We gonna...
I don't think I need any of this.
She leveled that.
What am I gonna do with all this useless money?
Money!
I can't pay them to stop shooting me!
Be careful.
Be careful?
Why?
What are... Oh, wait.
Is this the...
Is this the fucking thing where, like, he turns into a bat?
She sold out.
Wait, is this the bat level?
Oh, fuck!
This is the bat level!
Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna... I feel like I should buy the rocket launcher.
Alright, is it worth to buy the rocket launcher for the fucking Batman?
Oh, I missed out on this ammo.
Where the fuck?
Where's... Oh, there it is.
All this money in...
Well, you told... No!
No, it's not?
Okay.
You know what?
I'll... I'll fucking...
I'll do... Okay, cause he's the bat.
I'm gonna do it...
I have that money for this!
I'll just do the ammo capacity.
There we go.
Then I can have more ammo now.
I didn't put more ammo in there.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's bat time.
Alright.
It's Batman time.
We don't need reload.
We're gamers.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's Batman time.
Batman!
Oh!
By God, he did learn to fly.
I told him to learn to fly and God gave him the power.
What's your religion, sir?
Can I join it?
I mean, if I ask for flying powers and I instantly get it, maybe it's a good religion!
You're a shitty missionary.
You know that.
Oh, almighty.
Grant me the strength to crush your enemies.
Son of a bitch!
Ashley, run!
Run, Ashley!
Find the locker!
Find a locker, Ashley!
Oh, fuck!
This is where I die.
Sleep, think of a tent and get the chip!
I just think of thank you!
Oh, uh...
You wanna get ugly?
Oh, God.
Let's get ugly.
Don't worry, I have the rifle.
Okay.
Do headshots!
Oh, shit!
Oh, I'm sorry!
I have kitchen knife!
I'm... Okay, those quick time events were way too quick.
Shank!
To think you could be this foolish.
Control!
Okay, that's dumb.
Judgement!
Oh, God.
Oh, what?!
Oh, my God!
Please get up!
Please!
Ah!
Spray!
The real quick time...
The really, really quick time event.
Oh, my God!
Stop!
Knife!
I need a reload!
Evade!
Super quick!
I!
Okay.
There we go.
Aim for the spine?
How the fuck was I...
Guys, I can't tell what I'm doing.
What's ahead?
What's...
What's ahead and what's not?
Okay, now I know why we up... Guys, now I know why we fucking up...
Why we have to upgrade reload.
Now I understand.
Wait, the seat...
Does that not take damage?
Like, does this not matter?
Oh, fuck!
Fire!
There we go.
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
He's gotta pick it up again.
Dodge!
Ouch!
Okay.
Okay, I didn't dodge, guys.
It's okay.
I can tank another one.
I can tank anoth...
There we go.
I can tank one more hit.
You gotta pick up the barrel.
It's like Mario.
I can tank one more hit.
You gotta pick up the barrel.
It's like Mario.
Oh, he doesn't pick up the barrel!
It's not like Mario!
Guys, I made a mistake.
It was not like Mario.
Guys, it was 100% not like Mario.
Guys, it was not like Mario, guys.
I learned.
It was definitely not like Mario.
Oh, shit!
Bro!
The actual Quick-dive!
Okay.
There we go.
The weird Mario.
Okay, this is not a platform.
Oh, shit!
An eye.
Just like Mario.
Oh, there we go.
I knew it.
Hoarding was always the right answer.
Alright!
Here we go.
Thank you for the eye.
Give my regards to your god.
Is there any loot?
Okay, nice.
Oh, my god!
There was a lot of loot.
Give me a sec, Ashley!
I need the loot!
Guys, I might be inhaling a lot of smoke, Ashley, Ashley, but this is important!
This is very important to Leon!
Give me a sec!
Okay, let's see...
Look, I know I'm inhaling a lot of smoke right now, Ashley, but you don't understand.
Alright.
There's a ladder?
Oh, there is!
Okay, here we go.
Don't worry.
This fire is really fucking hot, but don't worry.
It's dangerous!
Ashley, you don't understand.
My love for loot transcends danger.
She will never understand.
Okay, oh, that is herb.
That is herb.
Okay, let's see.
We can combine that.
And then we definitely need more...
Wait, do I... Okay, we need more shotgun ammo.
Alright, let's just reload that.
And then...
Alright, I'm gonna definitely upgrade reload speed.
I realized my mistake when I said I'm not upgrading reload speed.
I realized that might have been a mistake.
Did I just... Okay.
Guys, we didn't see that.
Wait, I missed him?
Nooooo!
Ashley, no!
Thanks.
Nooooo.
This fire is bound to catch their attention.
Nooooo!
Leon, you're not gonna turn into one of them, right?
Nooooo.
I don't know.
Maybe their god is, like, worth it.
Like, they get special powers.
I grabbed the eyeball though.
I got the eyeball.
At least I have the cool eye.
I can't believe it.
That loot... What do you mean always see that map?
There's literally nothing!
Oh, that loot...
It wasn't treasure, right?
If Ashley turns into a monster and Leon kills her, does she drop loot?
Very good question!
Okay.
There we are.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, there's a treasure behind me.
Ashley, there's a treasure behind us.
Where is it?
More is looking up.
There it is.
Thank god I didn't see... I saw that.
Thank god.
This time I looked at the map.
Do you think Leon can use damage?
Or just shot... Dude, look at him.
Unless he's a fucking greasy ass dude, I'm pretty sure he uses...
No, there's no way.
Leon definitely is not like...
He's not a NEET.
So like, I'm pretty sure he uses conditioner.
He wants to continue the bloodline.
Well, at least we don't have to worry about being followed.
Come on.
Yeah, his hair is way too shiny for no conditioner.
I actually... I don't use conditioner because like...
I used to swim a lot as a kid.
And because of that, I fucked up my hair.
Because like as Asian parents do, they make their kid do lots of swimming lessons.
They make your kid do a lot of different lessons.
So then I like did a lot of like swimming lessons and stuff.
I never got past a single level because I couldn't do the butterfly stroke or like the frog.
I call it the frog because they called it a frog.
And I like failed three...
I failed the class three fucking times because I could never do the frog.
I retook the class three fucking times.
And it's not like...
Every time you take the class, you do the frog.
You have to learn all the things in that class the same time.
Like all...
You have to like always learn that same thing over like all the other steps.
Not just the froggy thing.
So like, you know, I have to keep retaking it three fucking times.
And I could never get the frog right.
So I failed three fucking times.
And every time I had to learn the basics.
Front stroke, backstroke, all that shit over and over again.
But it's always the frog.
I could never do the frog.
Anyway, the moral of that story.
I don't use conditioner because like my hair like gets like natural...
Like it's like...
Gets like greasy really really quick.
So like I always have to take like...
Because of like the swimming ruined my hair.
So like I couldn't do conditioner anymore.
Because like my scalp is like super fucked up because...
So I...
So like I used to use conditioner.
But like I had to stop because like my hair got super fucked up that I could never...
I can't use conditioner anymore.
Let's see.
And that's the moral of the story.
All right.
Next.
Trauma dump.
Sorry for trauma dumping by the way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Perfect.
With all that chlorine you got your hair bleached for free.
Ciao!
How does he have my phone number?
Who gave him my phone number?
Did I give him my phone number?
Did I slip in my number?
Did I slip in my number before he left?
I was like, hee hee, haha, here's my number, hee hee, wink.
Oh god, all those crows, you know you owe me money, crows.
Okay, let's grab some fucking barrels though.
Nice.
Oh hey.
What's this?
The vintage compass!
That's good, that's money!
Where the fuck is my merchant?
Is he in here?
Merchant!
What do you have?
What is this?
Increase the drop rate of red herbs.
I don't need that.
Exclusive...
Exclusive upgrade regardless.
Wait, what does this say?
What does this mean?
Oh, treasure map!
We need that.
Oh, I don't have anything anymore.
Nevermind.
I can't even afford that.
Okay, I can't afford anything.
I'm poor!
Alright.
Let's see.
Blacktail?
Is my gun the strongest right now?
Wait, is this?
Oh, that's a...
Wait, the semi-automatic rifle.
The broken butterfly.
Oh, resources!
Wait, I can buy resources now!
Rocket launcher.
Magnum ammo.
Wait, are any of these pistols better than my original pistol?
Get the stingray?
Why?
Stingray.
Three times power against weak points.
Wait, is that a rifle?
Is that like a sniper?
Oh, sniper would better fire it.
Broken butterfly, best magnum?
Ooh.
Do I buy...
...a magnum?
Is that better than my pistol?
You can get... I think you get magnum for free from a puzzle?
Okay, I'm gonna buy the rifle.
This is... uh... it's on sale?
It's for bosses.
The butterfly?
Which one's for boss?
Guys, which one's for boss?
Oh, magnum is a boss killer?
Oh, that's good.
I love boss killers.
...the things.
Gun's not just about shooting.
It's about reloading.
You'll know what I'm talking about.
Go on, take this as well.
Oh, nice.
I love free stuff.
Thank you!
Knowledge is power.
Remember that, mate.
Will that be all then?
Okay, does that mean I can throw this away?
Can I throw the SR?
A bolt action...
Wait, can I sell this now?
Guys!
Can I sell this now?
The SR?
No?
My rifle's better?
Wait, guys.
Which rifle's better?
Which is better?
The SR or the...
Um...
SR is the better rifle for power?
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna go for SR for the power.
And then I'll upgrade this.
Singer is better...
Guys.
You all have different opinions.
Okay, I'll...
Trust.
Okay, I'm gonna trust the guy that says trust.
And I'll upgrade my... I'll upgrade my magnum.
Boom.
Okay.
And then I'm gonna upgrade the reload speed of my fucking shotgun.
Because I realized...
Okay, now, guys.
Now you can talk to me again.
I'm broke again.
I'm broke, guys.
I'm broke.
I'm broke now.
Alright, let's see.
Do I have enough crafter?
Wait, I could've upgraded...
No!
I already used all my fucking money on suit...
Oh my god, where's the suitcase?
No, you guys are lying!
There's no suitcase upgrade!
What do you mean?
There's no fucking...
Okay, okay.
I almost got tricked.
Alright.
I almost got fucking lied to.
I was like, no!
Alright, it's okay.
Wait, what?
What is this?
Adam Sandler?
Oh no, it's a little boy!
The evil boy!
Tiny evil boy!
I can snipe all these people!
The dragon!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
What you got is for power.
Stinger is for DPS, which is...
Which one you like more is I like power.
Can I just snipe you now?
No, he's way too far.
I can't do 300 meters.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, we gotta go here.
What are you scared of?
Oh, I forgot to keep my voice down.
Okay, we go this way.
Let's see.
Yeah, we have to go this way.
Whoa!
What's that?
Bro, when was the last time there was castle maintenance, guys?
Wait, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
People dying?
Okay, boot knife.
That's better than kitchen knife.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, what the fuck was that?
Oh, that's not good.
Now they're fucking upgraded now.
Oh no.
That is not good.
Don't let him get too close.
Well, that's great.
I have fucking Ashley with me.
I would love to not get too close when this bitch is here.
Boom.
Nice.
Got shotgun shells.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna... that's the boss killer, right?
Okay, we're gonna put that shortcut... no, this shortcut...
There's a boss killer.
So, like, it should be over here.
And then we'll put this here.
There you go.
This is not good.
They're one... they were not one hit.
Did you not see how many fucking bullets it took?
That was not one hit.
What do you mean?
That was 100% not one hit.
Okay, sorry.
I had to make sure there was no door.
Oh, they can one hit me?
Oh, that's different.
That changes everything.
Wait, that actually changes everything.
Alright, let us... let us craft some more shotgun... I don't have enough shotgun.
Okay, nevermind.
Let's not craft.
Hello?
Oh, I don't like that.
They're chanting something.
Wait, how did they see me?
What?
Is that Beau?
Oh, that is.
Okay.
I don't think they can hit that.
Guys, I don't think... oh, wait.
Don't worry.
I can use this as cover.
Where are they?
Come on, peek me.
Come on.
What the fuck?
That's bullshit.
I see you.
What?
What are you doing?
Whoa!
Ashley, please stay behind me.
This is bullshit.
The way they're hiding.
I hate this.
Look at them!
Look at the way they're hiding.
Look at these cowards.
There we go.
Like, you're gonna get shot.
You might as well just peek me.
There we go.
Like, you're gonna get shot regardless.
Alright, here.
We got the fucking gunpowder.
Like, just fucking peek me.
They're very stealthy.
Okay, that's not cool.
That is not cool.
I like how it...
I get the cutscene after.
Yes, they do.
Where is it coming from?
I don't know where the catapult is.
Like... Oh, it's over there.
Okay.
Ashley, please.
Please do not get catapulted.
That is my only dream, Ashley.
There we go.
I don't know how I saw it, but there it was.
Oh shit, wait.
There's more than one?
Wait, where's the other catapult?
Where the fuck is the other catapult?
Okay, I gotta make sure...
What?
Where did you come from?
Nigs.
I got your butt.
Nice.
Where the fuck did they come from?
Ashley, are you alright?
Yeah, thanks.
Oh Jesus.
Where's the next catapult?
I don't know where the next catapult is and that's the scary part.
No!
No, not over here!
Who should... Hey look, there's a gem.
Oh my god, it's over there.
There's no barrel!
How am I supposed to get it when there's no barrel?
Oh god.
Oh god, there's no barrel.
There's no barrel.
I don't know where it is.
Oh, what the... What?
Shit!
There you go.
No, stab, please don't turn.
You get one shot apparently.
Okay, I'm gonna see if I can see the barrel from here.
No, I'm not.
What do you mean?
I am not okay.
Oh god.
Oh god, it's blocking every... It's blocking everything.
Where do I go?
I'm so lost!
I'm so lost.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, where do we go?
There's so many areas!
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
Ashley!
Ashley, there it is!
Downstairs!
Okay.
Okay, I don't know where to go.
I'm just gonna stay back here.
This is the beginning.
This is the...
I went the wrong way, Ashley.
I went the wrong way.
I went backwards.
Ashley, I'm sorry.
I'm so lost.
Ashley, I don't know where is left and right.
Ashley!
Wait, I can craft though.
What do I need though?
Do I need a rifle?
Ashley, give me a sec.
Uncle Leon is trying to figure out ammo management.
Uncle Leon needs to work on his ammo situation.
Is it here?
No!
It's locked!
Oh my god, Ashley!
There's a barrel down!
Look!
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, I need to figure this out again.
Okay, Uncle Leon doesn't know what to do.
Uncle Leon is so fucked up right now.
Oh!
Oh, there, there, there, there!
Here we go.
I figured it out, guys.
I'm not that stupid.
This could work.
Okay, what's this?
Oh, I can shoot the cannon!
Oh my god.
This could definitely work.
I like that.
Okay, I'm gonna bring out the shotgun just in case I get like shocked again.
Please, why are there no lockers in this castle?
Where are my lockers in this castle?
How do I get out of here?
Uncle Leon is lost again.
Was there an exit here?
The accident...
Oh, there was a ladder!
It's painted yellow!
I should have known.
I should have known the yellow paint strap.
I always forget about the paint strap.
The barrels though.
Why is there so...
Wait, I could have shot this!
Oh my god, they were there this entire time looking at me.
Wait, where's Ashley?
Ow!
What?
How?
How did you get injured?
Okay, this is awkward.
Alright, let's just hope no fucking catapult kills her.
Like, this is all I'm betting on.
Wait a minute.
Where did you come from?
I'm going all in with the catapult not fucking me up.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh shit.
Oh, she's okay.
That's good.
That's all that matters.
She's okay.
She's okay, guys.
There we go.
Alright, we're okay.
We're okay.
Holy fuck.
How?
Awesome.
Oh my god.
Bro!
Okay.
Guys, it had to be done.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, we need...
Couple of...
We need like two more blues.
Where's another blue?
I swear to god there were more blues somewhere.
Swear.
Swear I saw a lot of them.
The gate?
Oh, is that the gate?
No, there wasn't.
Liars.
There's no blues here.
Oh, there's a blue here though.
There we go.
We need two more.
Oh, yeah.
No, it doesn't have it.
This map...
We didn't pick up the...
We didn't pick up the quest yet for this.
We'll hit the gate with the cannon later.
We gotta do the side quest.
This side quest is more important.
Guys, no, no, no.
We have to...
There's two more that we need to do.
This side quest is the most important thing right now.
Is there anything in here?
Maybe I'll look down here.
I'm gonna double check if there's...
Oh, there it is.
There's one here.
Nice.
Yeah, there's one here.
Okay, we're missing one more.
We're missing one last blue.
There's one below on a tree.
There's so many trees.
We're literally in a forest.
This castle is in the forest.
Which tree?
Oh, I didn't see this.
I was so fucking panicking.
I didn't see all these boxes.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, wait.
I didn't see this too.
Oh, my God.
The elegant bangle.
There's so much loot.
The green tree.
It's over there, Doki.
That tree right there.
Doki, it's right there.
Doki, that tree.
God, it's over here.
The greener tree.
You know, that one.
Yeah, that tree over there.
Trees by the merchant.
Oh, it's by the...
You know what?
You could have said that.
You could have just said tree by the merchant.
Boom.
Oh, I see the request.
The request is right there.
Okay.
Wait, my bad.
It's the other tree.
Sorry.
My bad.
I meant that tree.
Yeah?
Tree?
There's no trees in the fucking castle, guys.
Oh.
Boom.
All right.
Here we go.
Now we have the request.
It's right here?
Where is there?
Okay.
Actually this is important.
Uncle Leon needs to get the medallions.
Because uncle Leon needs fucking upgrades.
You don't let Uncle Leon do this.
You don't love him.
How do you get downstairs again?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
We need to grab that tree.
That's apparently over here.
Thank god Leon doesn't have stamina bars.
Thank fucking god.
Where is it?
Where is this tree?
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
It's that tree right here.
There we go.
It was that tree all along.
Okay, reload.
I gotta make more shock enamel later.
Nice.
Reload.
Alright, we're good to go.
Alright Ashley, we're going in!
Yeah!
Open sesame!
You have stuff?
Sell it!
I did it!
Okay.
Do you have the box upgrade?
No, he doesn't.
Okay, I need a... what the fuck?
Oh yeah.
I can sell that.
I can sell this.
Do I have two circles?
No, I don't.
I don't have two circles yet.
So I'll just sell these for now.
I'm gonna sell this.
Sell time!
Save.
Nice.
Alright Ashley, here we go.
We're about to be at the part where I have to play as you and that's gonna be the worst part.
Hello?
Adam Sandler?
Please, little boy!
Mr. Kennedy.
Who the hell are you?
Me?
Oh please, call me Ramon.
And allow me to get straight to the point.
I would like you to hand the girl there over to me.
Now.
You have that chance, Ramon.
He has a Benjamin Button disease.
With me.
Mr. Kennedy.
There's no- he's 20?
Holy shit.
What happened?
This man was stressed way too hard.
Yes?
Never!
You are the lady.
I was fortunate.
I just love it.
Her fucking outfit.
You make Sarah Fierce feel so cool.
Now that he has chosen death.
Look, Netflix was just not as lucrative.
Okay?
The Netflix deal ran out.
Oh my god.
Excuse me?
That was a lot.
Oh god.
Stay close to me.
Stay close!
Wait!
No!
Okay.
Reload time.
I swear to god, do not get hit, Ashley!
That is my only demand!
Oh!
I missed every shot!
That was aw- That was aw- Okay.
That was a little awkward there.
That I sort of missed every shot.
It's a little awkward.
Alright.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
We survived!
We are survivors!
There is like so much loot upstairs.
God damn it.
It's in the chest.
Okay.
I will just smash some jars.
It's not my home.
Not my home.
Smashy!
Smashy smash!
What is this?
God, I don't have anything.
Why is it so foggy?
Did someone put like some fog machine in here?
Wait, Merchant.
You just watched this happen?
Oh shit!
There was a fucking bat like fucking two meters away from you, sir!
Bro!
The most evil guy.
Ramen salad pie.
Yoshi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
There is like nothing I need to do here.
I'm just gonna save.
Alright.
Here.
Merch just...
The merchant...
If it's not gold, it doesn't matter.
Can I open this door?
How would I be able to go in?
Oh, I have to drop down from there.
Okay.
There's so much loot, but I cannot get any of it.
Gap in the wall.
Oh, Ashley, go in.
This is your only job.
I don't ask for much, Ashley.
Ashley, I ask for almost nothing.
Please.
This is the only time I ask for anything.
It's open.
Okay.
There you are.
Nice.
Thank God you're useful.
Thank fucking God.
Ashley, I don't ask for much.
Oh, okay.
I thought I had to like make her go through this too.
Look for another way.
Oh, is this?
Oh, okay.
It was not...
Ashley, go back.
I didn't realize this was where I was supposed to go.
I have to still loot.
Ashley, looting is still important here.
Okay.
There is a chest.
Oh, elegant perfume bottle.
Something I can sell.
Okay.
Let's see.
That is the door where I can't open.
Knock, knock.
I'm alive.
Okay.
We're going to save again because...
Because like, you know, every time you make a mistake, you're going to get a kill.
You're going to make a little bit of progress.
You got to save so you don't want to...
This is efficiency because what happens if I fucking just die?
Because I don't want to do this again.
Every time you make a little bit of progress, you have to save.
So you don't have to...
That's why I have 51 saves.
This is exactly why we have 51 saves, guys.
It's just efficiency.
Because what if I just die?
With me.
Okay.
I just...
Nice.
Okay.
It's made of wood.
So I can...
I like how it's just that.
Is there nothing else?
I hear something.
Oh, it's above me.
Okay.
I knew it.
I was like, I hear it.
Okay.
Let's see.
I knew I heard something.
Wait.
What's that treasure?
Is it not...
It must be above.
It must be above because I can't get it.
Looks like we can continue on this way.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
It's dark.
I hate it.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Okay.
He's definitely dead.
Oh no.
No.
This is a torture room.
Is there any...
Oh my gosh.
No.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Can you move?
Can I not just like untie him and like fucking move?
I was awoken in the middle of the night once again.
It's those awful noises coming from the basement.
The sounds of nails clawing at the stone walls and the writhing moan of curses.
That man harbors enough hate to ruin this world.
He once served the lord of the castle as a torturer, like his father and grandfather before him.
It's one of the most unsightly legacies left by the Salazar family.
Even among his family, he was special.
He enjoyed his work wholeheartedly and had a talent for it.
He was gifted at tormenting others.
His ability soon attracted the master's interest.
And when he took him to the dungeon...
No, I can't write anymore.
I won't.
I don't want to recall what happened down there.
My mind can't take it.
It will break me.
I was ordered to attend him, to feed him, dispose of the fifth.
All while living.
Listening to that wretched voice every night.
I can't take it anymore.
I've had enough.
I'll not tolerate one more night in this castle.
I shall leave tomorrow.
Go far away, where that voice cannot reach my ears.
Damn.
Bro, your voice was shit.
Definitely won't be doing any ASMR.
None shall escape.
Okay, Salazar?
Like that little guy?
I assume...
I assume the little guy is Salazar.
And like...
Like his voice reminds me of an actor.
Like, I swear.
Like, it looks just like him too.
Like some old-timey actor from a long time ago.
Oh, hey, the Iron Maiden.
I'm trying to like remember who.
Like his whole voice too.
What was that?
I was having a satchel dog.
No, like there was an actor like that.
It sounds and looks just like him.
I can't remember who.
Don't worry, I have my shotgun.
Don't worry, don't worry, Ashley.
I have my shotgun, Ashley.
Don't worry, something's going to come in here.
Don't worry.
Something's going to come in here.
Hehe.
The time...
The light is lost.
I fucking knew it!
It's okay, I have the shotgun!
Oh, where would the shotgun go?
Which pattern is better?
Can I just kill him?
Okay, guys, can I just kill him?
Is this... yeah?
Try!
Why?
Tell
me to shoot him!
Why didn't you tell me to shoot him?
Okay, okay, I have a grenade.
Boom!
Oh god, I ran out of ammo!
Why
did I shoot him?
Oh god.
Oh my god, bro!
Invade!
Fuck, invade!
I forgot he's blind.
He's blind.
Don't walk into anything.
Don't!
No!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
He's blind!
Okay.
It's okay, we did it.
There goes my healing items.
There it goes.
I don't need a heal.
I don't...
There goes all my heals.
There it goes.
Woo!
Hey, but I got 3 shotgun ammo out of that.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Okay.
Okay, that was a little stupid of me to just shoot him.
That was...
That was a little stupid of me.
Not gonna lie.
And then I kept running into the spikes because I got scared.
Because I was panicking.
I got a little scared, guys.
I can't think when I'm scared.
I don't think when I start panicking.
All I can think of is like shoot.
Shoot the gun.
Doki, just shoot the gun.
Worry about stuff later.
Just shoot.
Open the door.
What happened down there?
Lots of things happened.
I don't know what happened.
Fear makes you do crazy things.
I need to go save now.
I need to grab those heal sprays I stocked up on.
Where are my chickens?
I missed the chickens.
If only I have the chickens.
Remember when I had all those eggs?
I remember.
That was the good life right there.
Welcome.
What can I interest you in?
Is that bango for circles?
It is.
I need like two reds.
Suit yourself, strength.
I missed the chickens.
I missed the free eggs.
Those were luxurious ta- I didn't know it was a luxury!
I didn't know they were a luxury!
Can I use this?
No.
That's the dungeon key.
Can I use the dungeon key for anything?
I don't think so.
No eggs for me.
Why can't the fucking castle people raise chickens.
Where are my chickens?
Alright.
Use.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Gunpowder.
Oh, that is good.
We actually need more of that.
We do not have any shotgun ammo.
Please, Ashley.
Help is not a concern right now.
Oh, I hear a little toy!
Where is he?
There you are.
I see you.
I already missed, apparently, a few anyway, so...
That doesn't matter.
Oh, nice.
A spinel.
Herbs.
I need the yellow herb.
That's the only thing I'm missing right now.
Okay.
Did I get everything?
The treasury.
Oh, no.
I'm having some fucking...
fucking PTSD right now.
Seeing the treasury.
Oh, no.
Wow.
I'm confused.
Oh, no.
I see this and I'm confused now.
Okay.
There is lore.
The iron sword.
We got the sword.
What have I...
We got the gold sword.
Okay.
And then we got the rusted sword.
Oh, it's a puzzle!
Can we not open this?
What do we do?
What does this do?
Okay.
Alright.
So, obviously...
This one would be the rusted sword because...
he's killing people?
No.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Let's see.
This one will obviously be the gold sword.
Okay.
Let's see.
Because he's gold.
And then... Oh, no!
I'm right!
Wait.
I can ring those gongs by shooting them.
I can ring those gongs?
What?
But, like, what about this room?
This one has to be the iron sword.
And then...
Why is there one sword empty?
Why is this sword empty, though?
I don't have all the swords.
Oh, I don't have all the swords!
Oh!
I was gonna say, like, where the fuck are the other swords?
Like, where are the other swords?
Yeah.
And then...
What?
Did I waste my ammo?
What did I...
Oh!
Wait!
Okay.
It's deer, bird, snake.
Deer, bird, snake.
Okay.
It's a puzzle.
Wait, but which do I know goes first?
Deer...
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, it's time?
Oh!
Okay.
Order is not necessary?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Well, clearly it was not timed.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Now I don't think it's timed anymore.
Now I don't think it's timed.
This definitely did not feel timed anymore.
Wait, then what's this?
Why can I not ring that, but not the others?
This doesn't look like it's telling some kind of story.
Yes, I know, Ashley!
I know!
Okay.
Whoops.
Sorry.
That's not what I wanted.
Okay.
Bloody sword.
There we go.
Okay.
Bloody sword.
There we go.
And then iron sword.
Bah.
Rested sword.
Door open.
Alright.
Nice.
Of course I'm right.
Ashley, I didn't need your help.
That's what chat is for.
Ashley, are you chat?
No.
You didn't join my membership.
You're not subscribed.
When you subscribe to me, Ashley, then you can bat-seek me.
There's a fucking snake?
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Why can't I just step on it?
That snake.
Okay.
Ashley, you can only back-seek me when you subscribe.
Chaotic!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Fake fan.
I know, right?
Fucking fake fan.
Fake ass.
Oh, nice.
Gold bangle.
We need that.
Alright.
Out we go.
Oh.
Let's see.
Oh, I don't like this.
You're so smart.
Ashley, you're so smart.
Head for the courtyard.
Where the fuck?
Oh, that's the courtyard.
Okay, but there's loot.
Ashley.
There's loot though.
We can't just head to the courtyard.
We need to grab the loot.
Okay, there is- Oh wait!
Can we...
Lower the ladder?
Oh, that's so convenient.
Thank fucking god.
Wait, can I jump here?
I don't know if this is like for jumping.
Oh, okay.
Ring!
Wait, is that a snake?
Okay, that's a snake.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the snake?
Israel, thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you!
Can I jump?
Oh, I can jump.
Thank fucking god.
It's called...
Parkour!
You wouldn't understand.
You're not as cool as me.
Is that snake?
No, that's bird.
Where the fuck is snake?
Oh, wait.
I'll be back.
I'll be back, Ashley.
There's loot here.
Nice.
Okay.
Guys!
Oh, I thought I was gonna kick it.
Sashkin!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Chat!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay, we need to sell...
Wait, where did you come from?
Okay.
Do we not need the dungeon key anymore?
No, we don't.
Okay.
Whoa.
Sorry, I'm like fucking freaking out right now.
Gold banga...
and...
iron glass...
Can we... If the poison glands are removed, it may be... Okay, yeah.
Never mind.
I'm not gonna eat the snake.
I'm just gonna...
sell it.
Yeah, I'm gonna sell it.
I don't trust myself.
I feel like something bad is gonna happen if I try to eat the snake.
Alright.
Let's see.
We gotta...
Where the fuck is the ladder?
Oh, there it is.
We need to find the snake.
Jonesy!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Donated a Doki Leon.
Save the gun, please!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Maybe here?
Is the snake here?
Is this snake?
No, this is bird.
Wait, I was here.
I literally jumped from here.
I couldn't count.
It's this way.
Sorry, Ashley.
It was this way!
Boop!
Here I go!
Whoa!
Snake here?
Snake?
Where the fuck...
Where's the snake?
Where the fuck's the snake?
Bro.
Oh, in front of me.
Sorry, guys.
I'm blind.
Whoa, Ashley!
What the fuck!
Bro, I almost shot her.
I almost shot her.
I actually almost shot her.
Bro, she scared the shit out of me.
Okay, here we go.
Holy shit!
Ashley, don't do that.
That actually wasn't Ashley jump scare.
Don't fucking do that again.
Holy fuck.
That scared the shit out of me, man.
Don't fucking do that again.
Don't do that again.
Okay, shotgun.
Oh my god, 17 for Magnum?
Now we're using the Magnum until we fucking go to the boss.
The scene kid jump scare.
Scene kid!
You're never prepared for the scene kid.
Okay, gunpowder.
Nice.
What is this?
What is this, Salazar?
Hello.
No.
No, I'm not.
What do you mean by that?
What is this?
I don't like this.
I don't.
Salazar, I don't like this.
I don't...
Shoot the bell?
Where's the bell?
There's no bells here.
Where do you see the fucking bell?
Am I blind again?
Am I... Am I blind again, guys?
Where's the bell?
Guys, where the fuck's the bell?
I am using eyes!
I don't see no bell.
Use your third eyes.
Oh, the speakerphone!
Bro, where the fuck's the speakerphone?
Where did the speakerphone come from?
This is not good.
I'm gonna grab some ammo and some money.
Okay, this way is quest tab.
This way is items.
This way is loot.
Typewriter!
Typewriter.
Nice.
There are some parasites that have the ability to control their host.
This is basic knowledge among most biologists, but not much is known about it.
There are some parasites that are known as to how the parasites do it.
The following is a list of several such parasites.
The Dicro.
Once the larvae of the parasite migrates to the ant, they alter...
Oh, this is the last of us.
That's the mushrooms.
The larvae of this parasite makes their home inside the brain of a fish, such as the yellowtail and parrot bass.
Once infected, the fish makes its way up to the water surface where it will swim until eaten by seabirds.
Oh yeah!
So the reason why is that the birds, when they eat it, the parasite like...
The parasite can only like reproduce in their shit.
So like the fish, you know, the way it spreads is by bird poop.
I know this!
I don't know.
I don't remember when I learned it, but I know it.
There's parasites developed in the snail's eye stalks.
Oh, I've seen these.
They make it look like they're at a rave.
Those parasites make the snails look like they're at a rave.
This is also... A lot of them are just like...
A lot of them spread by bird poop.
They alter the snail's behavior and force it to move to the top of the plant to make it more visible to birds.
Once eaten by the bird, the parasite will complete its metamorphosis into an adult.
The rainbow snails.
Yeah!
They're in fucking pain and they are dying, but it looks cool!
Okay.
No...
This is the objective, so I'm gonna go this way.
Nope, the door is locked.
Alright, I guess we don't go that way.
I love it when we don't go that way.
Wait, does that make an open this door?
Yeah, right?
I can!
Nice.
Shortcut.
Yay!
I'll never go back that way.
Oh, can I just shoot it?
Oh, it's next to the door?
Wait, so I just shoot this?
Where?
Where's the speaker?
Or you mean the downstairs door?
Where's the door?
Hahaha!
Guys, where's the bell?
Oh, by the typewriter!
Other door!
Where's the bell?
Bell!
Oh, barrel though.
Bell?
Guys, I swear to fucking god, are you fucking with me?
Guys...
Hahaha!
I swear...
Outside this...
Oh!
Guys, I swear to fucking god, are you fucking with me?
There it is!
This one!
Right?
I don't want to die, I don't want to die!
Oh!
Like that?
It's too late now?
No!
Don't pause.
What happens if I do it?
Okay, I'm just gonna save.
Look guys, that's not a bell.
This is not a bell!
It's like those like...
It's a speaker!
Guys, it's because you didn't say speaker.
If you said speaker, I would have known what you're talking about.
But you said bell.
What the f*** is a bell?
That's not a bell.
Bells do not look like that.
I just realized I have to do the f***ing maze.
I just remembered the maze.
The maze f***ing sucked, man.
Fudge top!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, since you're a bird too, can you make sure you get yourself checked after this?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh no!
Doki!
God damn it.
I've got my rifle.
I got my rifle.
God f***ing damn it.
Here we go.
Ashley.
God f***ing damn it.
I hate this level.
I remember this.
Where?
Wait, what?
Who f***ing shot you?
Oh my god, I hate this.
I hate this.
Oh god.
This one sucks more as a...
This one sucks more in the O.G.
I knew it.
Ashley!
What?
Who f***ing shot you?
Shoo!
Where?
I don't see the arrows!
Oh my god, there.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
This is way worse.
I like the old one.
I got her.
Where did you go, Ashley?
Where did you go?
I am not okay.
I don't know why I said I'm okay.
I'm not okay.
I do not feel okay right now.
I do not feel okay.
Really?
I like the old one more because I can literally just stand still.
Unless that's a different level I was thinking of.
I know there was one where I could just snipe and stand still.
Oh god.
Where is it?
I hear them!
I hear... they're just breathing heavily!
Where are you?
He's just breathing heavily!
I'm below.
Okay, guys.
I need loot.
Guys, I need loot first.
I don't have a lot.
Please tell me I can crash shotgun.
So, thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, I need to make sure.
Wait, what?
Wait, what was that sound?
What is that sound?
Where are they?
What is that?
I don't like that sound!
Where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
Stop whispering!
Stop whispering, please.
Stop whispering.
I don't like it when you whisper.
I'm gonna get rid of these guys.
Okay, I just want to get rid of these guys first.
Like, I...
Okay.
Is he...
Okay, I don't know if I'm shooting him.
Is he getting shot at?
I can't tell!
Are you getting shot at?
Bro!
I'm just gonna use my pistol.
Like, that was... I can't believe I wasted my rifle ammo.
I can't believe it.
Bro, I can't tell if he's getting shot at.
Like, he can't tell.
Alright.
Is he taking damage?
He is, right?
No!
It's a waste!
My pistol can't kill him!
It's a fucking waste!
It's a waste of a good flashbang!
Jesus!
He's so tanky!
He's still walking!
I can't see them.
He's still walking.
Oh, he has a helmet!
That's cheating!
One grenade versus a hundred bullets!
Look, that's the risk I'm willing to take.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
Look, I need that flash grenade.
You don't understand...
Oh, there's a vase up here!
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
There's... there's two vases up here that I missed.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
Why is it intensifying?
Oh!
What's that sound?
Oh, God.
I'm scared.
I know there's one more.
Like, he's here somewhere.
He's here somewhere, guys.
There's one more.
Bro, I don't even have flash grenades.
What the fuck?
What are you guys talking about?
We don't even have...
I'm like, how...
We don't even have flash grenades!
Why were you yelling me?
We don't even have one!
I can't believe you guys yelled at me about the flash grenades.
When we never even had one.
I can't believe it.
There.
See, I told you eventually we will kill these guys.
We eventually...
We had enough bullets.
Oh my God, I could have shot this.
Here we go.
He doesn't know.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Not nice.
We're gonna use the shotgun.
Because apparently he can one-shot you.
There we go.
Wait, you're still alive?
Okay, it's pistol time.
Because I don't know if you have a head.
That's the thing.
Sometimes I don't know.
Oh God.
Okay, I can't.
Yeah!
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
I think that's all of them.
We're good.
And he just gives me money.
Nice.
The mouth is the spot?
Oh, okay.
I couldn't tell!
It's so hard to see if he has a mouth!
Like, where's your head?
I couldn't tell where the head was.
It's too confusing.
Like, he was just all mouth, no head.
Okay, I need the thing.
It's a worm!
You can't kill a worm!
You can chop it, but you can't kill it.
Okay, got the wheel.
Okay.
Wheel time.
Yeah, we're... Why don't I have salt?
Salt.
If only I had the salt.
Who just...
That is exactly what I've been missing.
Where?
Oh!
There!
Please stop!
Son of a bitch.
Oh, God.
I don't have... Okay, it's time.
Okay, it's time.
I know I have the quick thing, but I'm too scared!
Oh, shit!
Fucking hell!
I'm gonna use this spray.
Ashley, come over here!
Ashley!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
You got it.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, he jumped in the air!
He jumped in the sky!
He
jumped in the sky!
He jumped down!
Ashley!
We gotta lead him to the explosive!
This is our only hope now!
I don't have a lot of ammo anymore!
I'm fucked up!
Please tell me he's dead...
He's not dead!
Ashley!
OK, here we go!
Wait, let me68 It's fine.
We're really poor right now.
But we're fine.
We live.
Oh my god.
We're okay.
We're very poor right now.
Our economy is in shambles.
But we are okay.
I'm not even gonna bother using my fucking sniper.
Oh my god.
Bro, really?
Bro, I'm just...
Bro, I do not need sniper ammo to kill you.
I can see your head.
OH MY GOD!
Bro, he...
Actually, please.
Please.
PLEASE!
Catch it!
Oh god.
Holy shit.
Okay.
We're fine.
It's fine.
We'll use the pistol.
We literally do not...
We don't need rifles for this.
Like, our aim is good enough.
Oh my god.
Please tell me I have enough to craft.
Okay, we need shotgun ammo.
We're so poor.
I need yellow herbs!
Oh my god.
Okay, we're fine.
I think we're good.
I think we're good now.
I think...
I think we're okay.
Alright, time to use the wheel.
Time to use the wheel.
Oh my god.
We have nothing left!
Alright.
Awesome!
Yes, Ashley.
So awesome.
I don't have the bullets yet.
Guys, remember when I had 70 bullets?
I remember.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
Don't tell me there's more.
The economy hit hard.
Hello?
Bro, this part fucking sucks.
I miss sniping.
We go back.
If we trigger somebody, we go back.
Oh no.
Bro.
God.
There's only resources?
What about the sniper ammo?!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, it's like Mario.
It's just like Mario.
Oh my god, I don't have enough ammo.
Please!
I don't know if I can protect you.
No, this is it.
This is the sniper area!
Okay, Ashley, here we go.
This is it.
Okay.
Don't have a lot.
But okay.
Oh shit, okay!
Alright.
Oh my god, please Leon, you're not supposed to be missing right now.
Oh my god.
What do you want?!
What do you mean?!
Guys!
Chill!
Actually, chill!
Oh, thank you.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I have to... PLEASE LET ME GO!
Oh my god, get down!
Get down!
Get down, Ashley!
Okay, I'm fucking...
Jesus, Chris, I'm gonna knife now.
Thank god.
I just had enough ammo.
I actually just got enough ammo.
Thank fucking god.
Look at me, I'm so fucking poor now.
Got a drop down.
Oh my god.
Okay, craft rifle ammo.
Because, by god, we need this shit!
Okay.
Don't say that.
Don't fucking say that.
I'm back in the lower tax bracket.
What am I gonna do with $95,000?!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Nice.
We made it.
Red Hood, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, Ashley.
You're close.
Okay.
Alright.
Thank you.
Oh, thank god, there's boxes.
Your guns demand funds.
Why can't I just buy ammo?!
This is exactly why we're not doing the harder difficulty.
I would have been softlocked.
100%.
I would have been fucking softlocked.
Okay, let's see.
Wait, what?
Open up.
What do you mean?
What the fuck do you mean?
There's a gap in the wall?
Ashley!
God, open up for me, Ashley.
Robert, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, here we go.
I found more shotgun ammo, nice.
Ashley, cough later.
Open the door.
Please.
Okay.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Ashley, look.
I'm not coughing, Ashley.
Come on.
Looks like the right place.
What's going on?
Are you feeling the scene?
What's the inner scene kid saying?
Instead of worrying about her, worry about your own skin.
What?
Oh, they're controlling me!
Or he's controlling her.
I'm a prince child.
I'm a child.
Ashley, please.
Please, no more of your scene roleplay.
Ashley, give me my knife.
That cost like $30,000.
Ashley.
Ashley, my knife is more expensive than you!
Oh, man!
Ashley,
please.
She's got emo.
No!
You're supposed to be seen!
Not emo!
It's not just a phase.
Wait, where are we at?
Okay, we're starting chapter 8 now.
Oh, wait.
We've never seen our chapter results.
No!
Look at that!
That's almost 90%.
That's it.
Roost, come in.
Things went to shit.
We took refuge inside a castle.
These moons, they will not hear.
Say it.
Roost, you're breaking up.
Do you read me?
Roost!
Hello!
I lost her!
And she lost my knife!
Damn it!
So much for that.
My knife.
Wait, this is...
Oh, I got my knife back.
Okay, that's good.
That's alright.
I don't give a fuck.
I got my knife.
It's alright, guys.
My knife is still with me.
It took me so long to find her.
And now I have to try and find her again.
Wait, what's over here?
Huh?
I feel like there would be something here because there's a fountain and a courtyard.
The fish!
I'm gonna eat the fish!
Eat the rich.
That's why there's a fountain!
I knew it.
I knew there's a fountain here for a reason.
Nice.
Now I have food.
Okay, now I have fish.
Good.
Okay, this is a mess.
Give me a second.
This is a mess.
Okay.
Let us sort this out real fast.
No, I'm not kitchen knife.
The fish are gone.
God, I have so many resources but no fucking gunpowder.
This is sad.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
A little snack for me.
I really need it because I wasted so much money.
I wasted all my heals.
Oh yeah, super rough, man.
Do you have anything new?
Matilda...
scope...
None of these are good.
Wait, is there the box upgrade?
Body armor!
This is good!
Nice.
Okay, we needed that actually.
Let's see.
Stingray... Okay, we don't need any of this.
Alright, we have Oh yeah, we should get the yellow herb.
We might as well.
I feel like we should.
Okay, let's see.
Do I have enough gems?
No.
Don't... Okay, I can sell this.
I still don't have a submachine gun.
So I can sell that.
And then...
Anything else should be good.
Oh!
Inflation is hitting hard, man.
Hahaha!
Alright, we're good.
We're good to go.
Wait, can I upgrade my body armor?
Can I?
No, I can repair it.
Alright, let's see.
Reload speed...
Rate of fire...
Uhhhh...
Ammo capacity...
I feel like...
All those weapons to finish!
That's all we need!
Hahaha!
Ammo capacity for my pistol.
I might as well.
Hahaha!
We don't need the rifle fire rate!
We're so fucking healthy!
We don't need it!
I hit my shots!
Hahaha!
We're so...
We're okay.
We'll be fine.
Okay, fine, fine.
Fine, I'll do reload speed.
We're a bug on the back wall?
What?
What about the bug?
What about the bug on the back wall?
What about it?
What?
What do you mean?
There's nothing here.
Oh!
On the fountain!
There's a...
There's a bug?
Whoa!
What the fuck?
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck?
Did you guys see that?
Left side... Oh, hey!
Oh, there's a beetle!
There he... I thought you meant like... Game bug.
Hahaha!
I thought that's what you meant because my graphics started glitching.
I was like, whoa!
You're right!
Hahaha!
I was like, whoa guys!
You're right!
There is a bug!
Hahaha!
Okay, here we go.
Um, time to sell!
Is this for selling?
Right?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's for selling.
Hahaha!
That was the fence.
Yeah, I thought...
I thought like the game was broken.
Wait, now eat it?
Oh, well too late.
I sold it.
I care about money more.
Hahaha!
Whoops!
I ate.
I sold it.
Sorry, money was more important, guys.
Hahaha!
Alright, here we go.
Whoo!
Oh no!
Wait, what?
Are these guys dead already?
Oh, they are.
This is messed up.
Oh, what the fuck?
Are they all dead?
Oh, yeah!
They are definitely all dead.
Yeah.
I gotta go.
What's this way?
Oh!
I remember this!
Okay, I'm gonna try and...
I just sniped in?
Wait, do I go from here?
I'm so confused.
I don't see them down there.
See?
I don't think I should.
Are you scared?
Yes!
Hahaha!
I'm scared.
When you meet Emma, Yes, I am!
What are you... How is that a question?
Hahaha!
Alright, for one Akasupa, I'll vault over.
That's right.
Hahaha!
Yes, I'm testing you all.
That's right.
Put the money where your mouth is.
Hahaha!
That's okay, right?
The bribe!
That's right.
That is why I'm not vaulting over.
Hahaha!
Oh, okay.
I'm doing it.
Okay, Bacon, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, it was fine.
Hahaha!
There was nothing to worry about.
Alright.
The voice of... Thank you for the...
Thank you.
$100 well spent.
The voice of pestilence dwells.
Do it, you coward!
Hahaha!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
The voice of pestilence dwells in the flames, leading the pitiful souls to salvation.
Consign the crimson flame to its rightful place, where you shall be welcome to capitalism!
Welcome!
What if I just shoot him?
Can I just shoot him?
I'm gonna do it.
Do I take the shot?
Guys, I'm gonna take the shot!
This is like Sniper Elite, where you can shoot...
shoot somebody in the balls.
Do it!
Sorry to interrupt.
Oh, ow.
Should I have done that?
Oh, shit.
Maybe I shouldn't have.
Guys, guys, guys, I might have made a mistake, guys!
I might have made a mistake, guys!
Oh, this is it!
This is it!
Okay, nice.
Alright, don't worry, I got the kick!
Oh, shit!
Don't worry, I got another grenade!
Another grenade!
Boom.
Ow.
It's okay.
That did nothing.
Okay.
Whoa!
You're still alive?
Made it!
Not anymore.
Oh!
Okay, this is not good.
This is not good.
Guys, this is not good.
I don't know.
I feel like this is not a good time.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god!
Guys, I ran out of grenade.
Does it look like I have a flash grenade?
Guys, I know you guys want me to use a flash grenade.
Guys, oh, I do!
I do!
Oh, my god, it's time.
It's time.
This is it.
This is it!
Oh, my god!
This is very unlucky.
This is very unlucky!
Billy!
Triple kill!
Oh, no!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, my god, he just got it.
It's fine.
You can't get closer to me.
It's okay.
He's burning!
Oh, no!
Oh, no, not the one shot!
Oh!
Use a shotgun!
Bro, I don't have it!
This is not...
not a good thing, Leon.
We're super fucked up right now.
Super fucked up.
There's no hot air.
So he's thanking for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Where is he?
Oh, what the fuck?
Why is he still here?
Oh, my god.
Okay, where's the red guy?
Is that the red guy?
I can't tell.
Where is he?
Where is the king?
Where is the king of all of this?
Bro, I'm just gonna fucking...
Ow!
Okay, I can't dodge that.
I can't...
Where...
There we go.
That's it.
Okay.
Oh, what?
Oh, what a waste.
What a fucking waste.
That's for sure.
Okay.
Run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
...
London is calling.
Guys, that was the only way.
Dux, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was the only way.
What else was there?
I'm so scared I'm gonna accidentally kick the barrel.
I'm gonna wanna kick the barrel so I'm just gonna shoot it from here.
Guys, I was scared I was gonna kick the barrel!
It was understandable!
I'm stupid enough to do it!
I truly see no other way.
Alright, here we go.
Oh nice, loot!
Look at that, we killed so many people.
Yeah, but what if I knifed a barrel?
I could have knifed a barrel, guys!
Bro, I could have like...
stealthed that and killed everybody with the chandelier.
I just realized I could have...
I could have!
Guys, I just realized...
I could have saved so much ammo.
If I just...
If I just stealthed and got to the chandelier.
Why did I do this to myself?
I can share hindsight.
Yeah.
No way!
Guys...
I think...
I think I messed up.
Alright, but it won't be as...
Guys, this is not a stealth run.
Chat...
We're not pussies here.
Guys...
We're not cowards!
There's like...
money here.
I'm trying to like figure out where the f**k the money is.
Like here.
It's like here.
This is the Doki Run, exactly.
Doki Run is all murder.
Oh, I just missed money here.
The Doki Run is just purely murder.
Okay.
The Doki Run is also trying to f**king figure out where to go.
Oh, it's like where I killed that guy.
It's right here.
Right here.
Wait, no.
It's not right here.
What the f**k?
Oh, no.
Where...
Where do I go?
Oh, ho, ho, ho!
Where am I?
How do I get out of here?
Okay, I'm not trying to find loot.
I'm actually trying to figure out how to leave.
Oh, hey!
On the statue?
There's a statue?
Behind me!
It was like...
Back in the OG room.
Right?
Guys...
Doki map.
There it is.
There it is!
Nice.
We made it.
We made it, guys.
Okay.
Can I craft shotgun ammo?
Oh, thank God.
I have zero.
Oh...
It's always poverty hours here.
It's just always poverty hours.
How do I get here?
What do I need here?
Oh, I need Ashley.
Oh, this was like... that's so funny.
I accidentally scammed all of you.
I thought you could use this door.
The shortcut.
There was only one way in.
Alright, here we go.
Cause how was I supposed to know there was one way?
I haven't played the remake!
The remake is so different from the OG!
Bro, it's been like almost three years.
How the fuck was I supposed to remember?
You can stop right there.
Ada!
Bacon.
Murder, looting, and extortion.
The classic Doki run.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Well, after six years, that is one hell of a greeting.
Six years?!
Ada.
You don't seem surprised.
Has it really been six years, man?
Whoa!
Try using knives next time.
Better for close encounters.
My knife is a hundred thousand dollars.
More than that, Shudie.
So what are you working for this time?
Oh, Leon.
Leave the girl.
She's lost no matter what.
You know that!
It's just a phase, Ada!
Maybe you'll live to meet me again.
And then I might get you that greeting you were always asking for.
See, last time I superchatted, I was asking you to throw the boxes out in the Superfront gate.
And you only threw one box.
Pulled me twice to save on me.
How about we continue this discussion another time?
Oh my gosh, she disappeared.
She's so fast.
That's magic.
She got that bug.
Last person I thought I'd run to here.
Grandma.
Did she just jump out the window?
She's bad, man.
Okay, we have fun.
Okay, there's no up.
Where the fuck is the jewelry?
Okay, we have no key.
Is there any bells to...
Oh, there's a chest right here.
Okay.
Nice.
Got the clock.
Alright, we don't have the key for this yet.
So, we gotta go forward.
Wait, what?
What did I miss?
Door?
What is this bug?
This random bug.
Let's throw...
Let's throw a graph.
Let's see.
Oh, it's this, right?
Oh, we need two more.
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh, we need three...
One more.
I figured it out.
I'm so smart.
We just need one more.
It's right here.
I'm so smart.
Oh my god, how did she do it?
It's like everything was just in the room.
Okay.
What?
What do the...
What do they mean?
Oh, I can rotate?
Oh!
Okay.
That's what they...
What kind of...
Who designed this puzzle?
Wait, but what the fuck are these?
I assume it's like this and...
No, it has to be blue.
So, I assume that...
Just like that.
Right?
Not...
What?
It has to be blue.
Wait, I get it!
I get it!
Wait.
Okay, what's behind this?
It's a shield.
Wait.
Wait, I get it.
I get it!
Wait.
Is that...
God, I'm so smart!
I figured it out.
Let me cook!
It's a puzzle for children!
I told you I figured it out!
Alright, we gotta go.
Gotta go forward.
Here, the signal echoes through the mountains.
Rock becomes gravel and the castle wall crumbles.
Behold, the crimson shade of the night sky.
A river of tainted blood befalls the sea.
Sacrifice your life and the blood of your enemies.
What's that sound?
I don't like that sound.
I take it back.
Oh money though!
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
I have a shotgun.
Woah!
What was that?
There's a small key behind me?
You liar!
You fucking liar!
There is no key behind me.
There is no key.
Oh my god.
What the fuck was that?
What is that?
What was that?
Wait, what the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that?
Oh there's the key.
Wait I can go back.
I'm gonna go back.
Bro I'm gonna go back.
I'm gonna unlock that drawer.
There is no need for me to be back there yet.
Gonna unlock this drawer.
It makes me feel safe.
Nice.
Oh pocket watch.
Money.
Alright.
Here I go.
Free loot.
Don't wanna deal with whatever is over there.
Ahhhhhh.
Guys.
What chapter is Ashley?
Missions?
This is very important.
Oh god, why is the hallway so long?
What the fuck is that?!
Holy shit, that scared the shit out of me!
Oh my god!
That actually scared the shit out of me.
Holy fuck.
Is that Spada?
What are you?
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck are you?
Oh my god, you're getting too old for this job, man.
You're getting way too old for this job.
Oh thank god, there you are.
I know, what the fuck was that?
Okay, selling...
Uh, ornate mirror...
Okay, there's no...
Oh, I have jewels here.
Okay.
I have jewels for this.
Okay, wait.
We gotta do this.
It's money time.
It's money time!
Okay, double... we need...
One of this...
And then one of this.
Wait, can I do...
Triple... double red?
Is that it?
1.2?
Yeah, double red.
Nice!
We got the double red.
And then...
That's it.
That's all I can do.
Okay, sell, sell...
Sell, sell...
Uh...
Sell...
And then... nothing else.
I don't have anything else.
I'm poor.
Yay!
Is there anything I can tune up?
Wait, is my body... Oh my gosh, my body is so fucked right now.
Okay, uh...
I don't think there's anything I really need to upgrade.
We're gonna hoard.
We're gonna keep hoarding our money.
But I will do the rate of fire.
I can... I can like...
Spare a little bit.
Maxi upgrade of the pistol?
I don't need... Okay, I'll do the rate of fire.
We gotta save money to make money!
Guys...
It's basic economics!
Save it for next game.
Wait, what?
Who said that?
Oh, fuck.
Bro, what?
He just stops talking?
Bro, why did you guys told me to shoot the bell?
Now I don't know what he wants me to do!
You said there'd be something special that'll happen!
The lore...
Now!
Now I don't have the lore!
Oh, there's a special upgrade if I max it out?
Okay, I'll do it.
What is it?
Guys, you fucking lied to me.
I got one guide again.
I got one guide.
I can't believe it.
No...
No!
Oh, it is.
You get it later.
No!
What's the lore?
I can't believe it.
I'll never know what the lore is.
I'll never know.
No.
I have to live with the actions of my consequence.
I have to live with it, guys.
Guys...
Guys, we're not boulders gating this, guys.
We have to live with our consequences, guys.
We can't just fucking skip the lore whenever we want.
I know that's what you guys want.
Ow.
Fuck, okay.
Okay.
Bro, fuck this.
I'm too tired of this.
I know it's that easy, but we can't just skip the lore whenever we want, guys!
Oh my god!
Bro, merchant, help me!
Wait, can they like not... Wait, I can just be here.
Wait a minute.
Wait, that's great.
I can literally... Wait, I can cheese it like this.
That's great.
Wait, I can't shoot it from here.
Cheesing again.
The Doki special!
Oh my god, he's so fast.
Oh my god, thank god!
It made him throw away his shield.
That's so good for me.
There we go.
Oh, wait, is he... Okay, he doesn't mutate.
Okay, thank god.
Alright, nice.
We're fine.
Wait, you're still... There's still one more?
Nice.
Okay, he's dead.
I'm pretty sure.
Thank god.
The Doki special!
If you can cheese it, there's a way.
Oh, it's a puzzle!
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
I'm gonna make sure there's like nothing up here first.
Okay, I think I see how this works.
Alright, I'm gonna make... Wait, the fuck?
What is he doing here?
Get out of here.
What are you doing here?
Oh!
Wow!
Alright, give me a sec.
Please!
Get on him!
Yes!
Good!
That's very helpful!
Oh!
That is very helpful, man!
Sab!
There you go.
Wait, now that I know I can just stab him, that is good.
That is good.
Now that I know.
I don't waste bullets from just...
I don't waste bullets from the spotters.
I can just shank them.
Let's back to London we go.
Okay, we do this.
And then...
We go down.
And then we open that door.
And then we go...
Boop!
And then...
We go... Doki's special.
We go here.
And then we go downstairs.
And then the doors open.
Ta-da!
Magic!
James, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Now I want to replay the game.
Damn it, why do you do this to me?
Alright, let's see.
I don't have enough for shotgun.
I'm gonna save up for shotgun.
Like, I feel like the shotgun is more important at this rate.
The rate I'm fucking going.
Drop down!
Wait, which way?
Oh no.
Is this the treasure room?
This is not the safe room.
Shake!
Wooo!
Shit!
Okay.
Okay, I did not think he'd be that close.
That was an accident.
Alright.
Okay, I'm just gonna shoot with you here.
Okay, nice.
You don't know where I am.
There we go.
Good.
Ah!
Fuck!
There we go.
Okay, I did not fucking see there.
Jesus Christ.
I did not see her at all.
Oh, that scared the shit out of me.
Fuck.
Okay.
At least we got shotgun ammo.
That is good.
We got shotgun ammo.
Oh, it's another puzzle?
Come on!
Wait, if that's a puzzle, then what's over there?
Wait, there's a...
treasure!
I'm looking up.
There's a treasure.
Treasure?
It's upstairs.
Where the fuck's the treasure?
It's above me.
How do I get above?
Huh?
It's like here.
That's not the lantern.
There's a lantern?
It's not that one.
That's the fire lantern.
That's not it.
Is that the lantern?
That's the fire lantern, you idiots!
It's not this one.
That's the fucking fire lantern.
There's no jewelry here.
I don't know.
It's something...
It's above me.
I knew that was the fire lantern.
There was fire in it.
Like, what else could it be?
It was literally fire.
I'm just gonna kill this guy though.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Come on.
Can't take another headshot.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, there he is.
You think you can scare me?
That's fucking right.
You thought you could scare me?
I see you.
I see you right there.
You ain't fooling me.
Alright.
Let us go back for the puzzle.
It's puzzle time!
It's our favorite!
Puzzle time!
I love puzzles.
Alright, where is this?
Okay.
Press this.
My brain expands a little bit.
And then...
Whoa.
Leon, you pulled out the guns out of nowhere.
Hmm.
I hear something above me.
I see you.
That's fucking right.
You think I didn't see you there?
That's right.
What the fuck?
Wait, I did not see you though.
I did not.
Where did you come from?
Okay, he didn't turn.
Okay.
Thank god.
I was like, wait.
I see you, but you?
Okay, money.
Guys, you need to drop something that's not money, guys.
Please.
That's all I ask of you.
Okay, and then we drop down from... wait.
We drop down from here.
We're like here.
Wait, no.
That has to be money.
Money?
No?
No money?
Where's money?
Oh, and then I do the...
And then I do the...
The lever?
I do the lever and then I go back and then there's money.
There.
And then I go back here.
And then...
Money?
Money!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
And then...
And then I...
Oh my god, I'm so confused.
Guys!
I'm so confused.
Okay, and then...
And then I...
I go here.
And then I go up.
And then I drop down.
And then money.
Money?
And then...
Wait, is there lantern here?
Lantern?
Is there lantern here?
Okay, and then I go up.
And then...
Okay.
I do this.
Nice.
Okay, we're good.
We're okay.
And then I unlock this.
And then...
Everything is good to go.
The doorway in front of the ladder?
What's that gotta do with money?
And then I can open this door!
And then...
Money.
There we go.
We did it.
We figured it out, guys.
How do we get there?
Wait.
Wait, no.
What did I do?
Oh, I missed out that door!
So stupid.
I didn't think there was a door there, Kev.
I didn't see the door.
No!
Okay.
I'm just blind.
Okay, and then we go through here.
And then...
And then we go up.
Here we go.
We're fucking thinking right now.
And then we go here.
And then...
And then we...
We turn on the lever here.
So it's sunny now.
And then we...
We go here.
And then...
Wait.
I hear things.
And then we turn this lever.
And then we go through this door.
And then we go down.
And then money!
We did it!
Oh gosh, we're so smart.
We...
What will you guys do about me?
What will you guys do?
What will you guys do about me, chat?
God damn it!
Come on!
Come on, guys!
What will you guys do?
I feel like you guys cannot live!
You guys won't be able to function without this genius brain!
Okay, we're gonna make sure we kill this guy though.
Like, you cannot comprehend my logic.
That's how fucking ingenious I am.
Okay, kick kick kick kick kick kick.
Yes!
Got it in time.
And then she- oh he's dead.
Okay, I thought I had to shank him.
Alright, nice.
I feel like this stage is taking much longer than it should.
Due to how ingenious I am.
Wait, where does this close and open though?
It's sun time.
Nothing?
Oh, okay.
It's morning now.
Is there anybody out here?
Oh wait, there's this.
What does that do?
I'll never know.
What the fuck did I just do?
What the fuck was that?
I'll never know.
It'll always be my little secret.
I don't like this.
What the fuck is that?
Excuse me?
How?
How do I kill him?
Oh!
What?
Why?
Can I kill him?
No?!
Okay, guys, apparently I can't kill him.
Where do I go?
Oh God, this way, this way.
It's yellow.
That means I go here.
What is he going to do?
Throw that rock at me?
That's fucking right.
You can do jack shit.
Follow the yellow!
Follow the... oh shit!
Okay, there's no way this hits me, right?
I need scientific reasons.
This hits me.
Guys, there is a way for this to hit me.
Guys, I found out.
There is a way.
There is a way!
Oh, fucking bro!
Get your knife!
Okay, so apparently there was a...
Why are you fucking kidding?
Bro!
This is not fair.
There should not be a way for you to get over here.
This is absolutely not fair.
This fucking sucks.
Just keep running.
Okay, try to get over here.
Maybe if I go down here.
Is this sanctuary?
This is not sanctuary.
This is loot.
This is just loot.
Oh my god!
Bro!
No, please!
No, let me up.
Let me up.
Oh!
Wait, what?
Is this way?
Lever time!
Okay, lever time.
Lever time.
And then I dropped down!
I did this out of order.
I did this out of... What?
What do you mean?
What do I do from here?
Why am I trapped here?
Okay.
No.
Oh, thank god you died.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna figure out this puzzle together.
I did this all out of order.
Okay, he...
He threw the... I'm gonna wait for him to throw one more time.
I'm gonna wait for him to throw one more time.
There's treasure in that room!
Okay, now we go back in.
Now we go...
I'm panicking!
There is!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Guys, I'm panicking.
I am panicking so fucking hard.
Brain no work when I panic.
Wait, the music stopped.
Is he like, tired?
He's not tired.
He was not tired.
He was not tired, chat.
He was absolutely not tired.
But it's okay!
I keep going!
Just keep running!
Just keep running.
You'll get there eventually.
I could've just knifed that, but I don't... I'm panicking.
I could've literally just knifed it.
And not worried about anything.
Oh my god, bro.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
I'm gonna... I'm gonna shake you.
Bro, I'm gonna...
Oh!
Bro, you guys don't deserve bullets.
We're good, we're okay.
The best part about the archers is that they don't deserve the bullet.
Like, I can just shake them and they'll be fine.
That's the best part.
I don't have to worry about...
I don't have to worry about wasting my ammo.
I knew how to do combat!
I've always known!
What do you mean?
I just don't want them to get close to me!
That's different!
I'm looking this way.
Nice.
Where is he?
Let's see.
Oh god, thank god.
Okay.
Holy shit, that was so long!
It took so long to move the cannon!
Who would've thought cannons are super fucking heavy?
Who would've fucking thought?
Oh my god, cannons are heavy!
It took so fucking long to move that... Okay, here we go.
Down, Ako.
Let me shoot the door.
Oh, but then I can shoot this.
Alright, down I go.
I'm not done with the cannon?
Oh.
Okay.
I never know when I'm done with the cannon.
Wait, what the fuck?
Where did these guys come from?
Oh, it's nice that they're turning their backs for me.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Okay, maybe they turn around when they hit this area.
Did they actually turn around?
What if I shoot you in the legs?
Oh, no!
It doesn't work!
Leg doesn't work!
But do you turn around after?
You do!
That's great!
You actually do turn around.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
We go back to the cannon, apparently.
Where did the cannon go?
Alright, I keep forgetting about the door.
Guys, it's so heavy to move the fucking cannon.
Oh my god, Ako shot the cannon at them like last time!
You're right!
Could've just done that.
That would've made it so much easier.
I always make things harder for myself.
Why do I keep doing that?
Wait.
There's loot here that I'm missing.
Where is that?
Here?
There's somewhere here that has loot.
Oh, here it is.
I don't have a key.
God damn it.
I never have the key.
Okay, I'm just gonna reload everything.
I never have the key for stuff.
Okay, shotgun.
Wait.
Shotgun.
Okay.
Throwing a cannon at the chest.
Okay, just shoot.
AHHHHH!
FUCK!
Oh my god.
Oh no, please don't tell me it's Crash Bandicoot.
No.
Oh, he's dead.
Okay, I just can't go back.
Oh my god.
Oh, I thought I had to do a Crash Bandicoot or some shit.
Thank god.
Thank god I live.
I lived.
Alright, anything in here?
No.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, is this the garden?
Is this the maze?
God fucking damn it.
It's the fucking...
Oh my god, it's the dog maze.
It's super dog time.
Oh no, not super.
Super dog.
Oh my god, not super dog.
Bro.
Bro, not super dog.
God damn.
Alright.
It's super dog time.
Ashley!
Ashley?
Ashley, I know it was just a phase, Ashley.
I know you didn't mean it.
I know you didn't mean it when you took my $100,000 knife.
Bro, you're a little girl.
You're gonna hurt yourself before you hurt me.
I'm so scared.
It wasn't myself anymore.
It was something else.
Ashley must have been terrifying.
I know.
You too.
I'm warbing.
It's okay to be afraid, you know.
And I'm warbed soon.
You can't.
You gotta keep moving forward.
We will beat this.
Together.
I don't know if I can.
You can.
Just yell out that you're gonna shank.
Just like me!
Just be like a Pokemon.
Ooh, nice.
92%!
Look at that!
Bro, I'm fucking gaming, man.
I'm fucking gaming.
Alright, we're...
Seven more chapters!
Alright, we're kicking good time.
We got to chapter 9.
Oh my god, can I make Ashley hide in the locker before I fucking do the...
Yes, I can.
I absolutely can.
Ashley, you don't understand.
I will run away the moment there's trouble.
There is 100% chance I can leave.
No, it's not.
Get closer.
Can we get to- I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get a buzz.
Save 100.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh no.
Wait, is Ashley coming with me to the dog maze?
No!
Ashley, no.
No.
Why?
Why must you come with me to the maze?
Can you please get kidnapped?
Ashley, please can you get kidnapped right now before I go to the maze?
Please.
I am directionless.
Ashley, please.
I am so bad with mazes, Ashley.
I really can't have you with me right now.
I swear.
All right, they owe me money.
Those fucking crows.
I'll never forget.
These crows owe me money.
Oh fucking god.
Okay, we got figure this out.
We have figured this shit out...
All right, we got one of them.
God, no.
Oh no!
No.
Oh... yeah.
I got my shotgun.
I'm ready for super dogs.
I got it ready.
I'm so directionless.
I'm gonna get lost so fast.
I can feel it already.
Guys, I can already... Oh god, it's super dog.
It's super dogs.
Doggos?
Where am I?
Oh, where am I?
I hear the toy.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Where is the toy?
All right, here we go.
I like how people are trying to give me directions.
It's not, guys.
It's hopeless.
You know damn well it's hopeless.
You can't fix this.
I know you guys think you can fix this, but you can never fix this.
I will...
I will forever be directionless.
There's no fixing this.
Oh god, I hear the super dogs.
I hear them.
They're to my right.
Oh, that's all of them.
Wait, if I kill...
Oh fuck, I thought I was gonna kill all of them now!
Oh my god!
Knife!
Kitchen knife!
I was like, okay, if I kill all of them before they got out...
It didn't work.
I didn't manage to kill all of them before they...
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought I didn't kill all of them before they got out?
Wow, Doki.
Super dog.
Super dog is coming.
Which way?
Which way are they coming?
I hear them, but which way?
This way!
I fucking knew it.
You can't hide.
You can't hide from me.
God, okay, wait.
How much ammo do I have?
Okay, we got a...
Yeah, we definitely need a shotgun.
I'm gonna go get a shotgun.
Okay.
Oh my god, they found me.
There you go.
That's fucking right, idiot.
Oh shit!
Oh, okay, he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
We're embattled.
He's just as lost.
The dogs are just as lost as me.
Oh, hey, chessboard.
Nice.
That's money.
Sweet, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, the tiredness is taking me now.
Thanks for the stream, Doki.
It has been very fun.
I'll watch the rest of the VOD tomorrow.
Alright, thank you for watching so far!
We had a great time.
Have a good rest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Dog?
Oh my god.
Okay, he run.
No, god damn it.
God damn it.
He just fucking came in here.
He should try and gank me.
Okay.
I think... you think I didn't see that?
You think I didn't see that dog?
Wait, did I kill him?
Did I like accidentally kill him?
He like just passed out at the end.
Nice.
Good.
I actually accidentally... accidentally shot him.
Where is this area?
God, I'm so lost.
Where am I?
Okay, there's loot.
I'm so lost.
I remember we were stuck here for so long.
Because I kept getting... Did I do this already?
Yes, this is the beginning.
This is...
This is the beginning.
This here, here.
We didn't go here.
I knew it.
There's a... there's a box.
Yellow box.
Here we go.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god.
Get out of here, super dogs.
Oh no.
Oh, that's a lot of super dogs.
Oh god.
Okay, there we go.
I killed them before they got me, and they got a flash grenade.
Let's go.
Wait a minute.
I hear a dog.
Don't think I didn't know they're here.
I hear...
I play Apex.
I hear everything.
Hold this down.
Don't think I can't hear your fucking footsteps.
That's fucking right.
Be careful?
Of what?
Okay, I don't like that you told me to be careful.
Because be careful of what?
What do I need to be careful of?
Yeah, I have the sound DLC.
If you're a good little boy, you too can get the sound DLC.
That means you are all bad little boys and girls.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Where are you Ashley?
Ashley, run!
Ashley!
Ashley, where did you go?
No!
No fucking way!
Oh my... I'm gonna shoot you in the fucking feet.
Oh shit, that's the wrong one that I shot.
There's dogs again!
Shit!
Okay, there we go.
I was gonna say, why are there dogs again?
You should be dead dead.
Okay, thank god.
There's always dogs.
Not the dogs.
Are you fucking... where's the dogs?
Where...
Oh, it's a freaking dog!
Okay!
I can't.
I really can't.
I can't deal with these.
I don't have the ammo.
I can't.
I don't... I'm fucking broke right now, Ashley.
I'm fucking broke right now, Ashley.
Okay, I think we're good.
I think we did it.
Okay.
Are you fucking... where?
Where?
How are you alive?
Are you okay?
No.
This fucking random dog that just ran away.
Train.
What's this?
For toilet... these are three...
Oh, okay.
It's just money.
How have we procured these curiosities?
These are all...
I don't have enough.
There hasn't been like a mission.
Upgrade!
Okay.
We definitely need to do this.
All right.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
There's so much!
Okay.
Exclusive time.
We can sell.
Sell.
We need two... we have all this stuff.
All different!
Okay, let me sell these first and then we can...
Uh, an extraordinary... Okay, imp that.
Alright.
If it's all different, do we... 5 gems... How many gems?
1, 2, 3, 4?
Uh, 1, 2, 3, 4, 4, 1.6.
I don't think we're gonna find...
Uh, I don't think we're gonna find like 4 of a kind.
I don't think so.
I think that's like almost impossible at this point.
So...
We can have 1, 2...
Oh yeah, there's no way.
Yeah, there's definitely no way.
There's no way we can get that.
We can have all of this though.
The different colors.
And then...
Stonks going up right now.
Look at that.
BAM!
Oh, yeah.
51,000!
Yeah, we're fucking... stonks going up.
Oh my god, time to use it all up.
Okay, we're gonna...
Repair our knife.
And then we're gonna upgrade our pistol.
And...
Our shotgun.
And our rifle.
Yeah, I think so.
Power.
Since these are like our most...
Uh, our most fucking used guns.
Yeah, I already fixed my armor already.
We're fine.
Armour's been fixed.
All that money gone so fast.
Oh, all that money...
It's already gone.
Now I'm back in the lower tax bracket.
I hear the dog.
Wait, I just realized...
I don't even have shotgun shells.
Okay.
Are there any fish in the pond or did I kill them all?
Wait, do they respawn?
Wait, do the fishes respawn?
Oh my god.
This changes everything.
The fish respawn.
Yeah, I hear the dog, but he's like not coming out.
Where's the objective?
I'm so lost.
How do we get there?
How do we...
Oh, gap in the wall.
How do we get there?
Oh!
I went the wrong way.
Okay, we're just gonna grab the treasure over there first.
Yeah, I went the wrong door, guys.
I just realized.
But like, there's a treasure over here anyway.
So... wait, do I have a key?
I don't have a key.
Yeah.
I went the wrong way.
Classic Doki.
Where's the dog?
Where the fuck is the dog?
Oh, there he is.
There's the dog.
There we go.
You have...
Oh, it's just money.
I don't care enough.
We have to go this way anyway.
Wait, how do I get there?
God damn it.
Where am I?
Oh, there it is.
This is where I have to go.
Wait, oh my god.
I don't care enough to find that area.
I don't care enough.
We're just gonna progress.
Here we go.
But the loot...
We'll go back later!
It'll be fine!
And she never goes back later.
She never comes back later.
Get some good news.
Now I can do more nasty upgrades.
Nice!
That's basically what I saw.
Wait, there's annoying blue medallions.
Oh, okay.
This is easy.
That's easy.
Oh my god!
It's that thing!
It's the...
Bonus!
We can do this.
Alright, Ashley.
It's bonus time.
This is it.
Watch this, Ashley.
Watch this.
Okay.
I have not... I've never used a TMP before.
So this is gonna be interesting.
Oh, is this pirates?
Oh, these are all pirates!
Okay.
I haven't used these before.
70 bullets.
Oh, I don't know!
Ashley!
Stop back-seating!
What?!
Okay.
This is a dumb gun.
This gun sucks.
How do you headshot that?
Okay.
There's...
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
There's...
There's no way!
Okay.
That's still an A.
Okay, guys.
That's still...
There's a single shot?!
Okay.
Right, guys.
Nice.
Okay.
This is easy.
It's just a shotgun.
Oh.
Nice.
Reload time.
I'm reloading!
Alright.
What?!
Okay.
That is bullshit!
How the fuck do I shoot that?
Okay.
Bro!
Bro.
Okay.
There was no way.
There was no way to dodge that.
The spread!
Guys!
The spread, man!
It's the spread!
Chat, it was the fucking spread!
Alright.
What do I get?
Hash bolt.
God damn it.
That's useless.
That's fucking useless for me.
Okay.
We need one more.
Alright.
Why is there a single fire in this?
High score.
Here we go!
I hate Ashley back-seeding me.
Alright.
Come on.
Oh shit.
Boom!
Okay.
Nope.
We don't shoot.
Guys.
Reload time.
Come on.
Reload.
It's time to reload!
We need the spread!
I'm ready.
Thank god I never got the PMP.
PMP plus sucks.
Oh fuck!
I'm sorry!
I got too trigger happy!
Okay.
It's like who innocent people over like 300 people I killed.
If I only accidentally killed one of them, after like saving the world, like I should get a pass.
I should get a pass there.
Like if I save the world and I only kill two people, like that's a win.
Okay.
Plus 15% ammo, craft bonus, frequent.
I don't fucking know what that is but...
That's literally all I have right now.
It's not a war criminal if I save it.
I saved the world!
If I saved like 300 people and only two people died, it's like just unlucky.
It's like just unlucky.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where is my...
How do I customize my case again?
Okay.
I need to go to my typewriter.
There we go.
Blues...
40% off resources.
Wait.
I already have this.
Which one is the...
Oh there you go.
I can only put three at once.
Magma bonus.
Okay.
I feel like I'm not gonna craft the other stuff.
Magma bonus.
Okay.
I feel like I'm not gonna craft the other stuff.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
We gotta go...
Jesus Christ.
Why is there so many fucking names here?
I don't have anything.
Where do I go?
Here?
Okay.
Objective is here.
Can I go here?
Like...
Is there any reason to be here?
Is there any reason to be here guys?
I don't know.
Should I be here?
I can't tell.
Oh it goes back to an earlier area?
Fast travel.
I love fast travel.
Where is this place?
Where am I?
Oh!
Oh I remember this place.
I remember.
It's the... It's the part where I was trying to find the fucking bell.
Yeah but I don't have any keys.
See?
I couldn't find any keys.
Cause like there's nothing to unlock.
Cause I don't have a key.
We'll come back later when we find a key.
This way.
Yeah but we don't have keys.
Yeah.
Hey this is it.
Red guy?
Who the fuck is red guy?
She does not come back.
It was from this moment on.
Chad knew.
She did not come back.
Don't worry guys.
I'm gonna come back everybody.
Don't worry.
We're gonna come back.
Let's see.
This way.
Is there anything here?
No it's locked.
It's locked.
Where?
Oh hey.
Can I shoot that?
Actually.
Why would I shoot that?
I could knife it.
Let's see.
Oh I forgot to shoot the medallions.
I almost forgot about the medallions.
There's a medallion above me?
Question mark?
Medallion?
What the fuck is...
Is it below me?
Maybe I'm gonna shoot this one first though.
I'm gonna shoot that one first.
Since it's over there anyway.
Okay.
We're gonna go this way.
Oh.
What's this?
Okay we need the Cerberus head.
Oh what the fuck?
Oh it's like here.
I was like where is that?
Rats have infested a section of the castle.
They are gnawing away at all the precious books.
But those heretics couldn't care less.
Okay it's time to shoot the rats as well.
There's so many things to shoot.
So little time.
There's only one Leon.
I assume this is the library.
Oh my god.
Where do I go?
What the fuck is this?
Guys there's...
Okay I don't know where to go.
There's way too many entrances.
There's way too many things in here.
There's a symbol on the wall.
Okay.
I have to do all the rooms?
I do?
Alright.
Let me figure this shit out.
Okay we'll go this door first.
This is gonna be a long chapter.
I can tell.
No it's the snake room!
No!
Okay let me...
I'm saving.
I'm getting...
I'm getting snake PTSD.
I'm getting snake PTSD right now.
Okay.
Okay let's see.
Alright.
Dining hall?
It's puzzle time.
No thanks.
Where's the rat?
There was a rat?
Rat!
Here we go.
We got the rat.
Pest control is here.
Wait what?
Order?
Sit there?
Oh I can like have her sit there while I do this puzzle.
That is so nice of her.
Okay.
Oh!
Okay!
I got this.
Alright I need you to sit...
Okay.
Napkin, two... two...
Two knives, Spoon fork.
Napkin, two knives, spoon fork.
Napkin, two...
That's three.
Two knives... wait is there bread?
No.
No bread.
Napkin, two knives, Spoon fork.
Spoon fork.
Go here.
Sit here.
Okay my turn.
Let's see.
Okay.
Three knives.
Two forks, one spoon.
Three knives, two forks, one spoon.
Oh I'm here.
I sit here.
This is my spot.
I did it!
Yeah!
We're so smart.
Looks like you figured it out.
Oh this isn't the bad snake room.
I thought this was the one where the fucking guy with the...
With the knives thing.
You know like the knife arms.
And then he slashes me.
I thought it was this room.
It's not this room so it's the other rooms.
If it's not this room, it's gonna be the other rooms.
It's gonna be the other rooms.
Yeah the cage fight.
I thought it was the cage fight.
Oh there's the red herb.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
We'll eventually get to that room.
I can feel it.
Check the map.
A Dallion!
Dallion?
Oh there it is.
Nice.
Thanks for the reminder.
Okay and then...
We gotta go here.
And...
Okay we gotta go like this.
Apparently.
Almost got it.
Alright.
Here we go.
Who has the snake head?
We might as well give him the snake head now.
I still left this guy.
Oh I don't even have to do the puzzle for this.
Thank god.
Thank god it's automatic.
Alright.
Here we go.
Is this combat?
This has to be combat oriented.
There's no way.
Leon there's some armor.
Bet you could use it like a bullet proof vest.
Little old fashioned for my taste.
Ooo.
Oh I can feel it.
I feel the...
I feel the gun fight.
Too bad.
Oh there you go.
Don't worry about shotgun.
I have my shotgun.
Don't worry.
Alright here we go.
Oh.
Here we go.
Woah.
Wow.
Actually let's go save our game.
Before we go downstairs.
There's a base here anyway.
So it's good that I came back.
Alright Ashley.
We're gonna save the game.
Don't have much.
So let's save.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
I could see...
The lion is like in the center.
That worries me a little bit.
It tells me that I have something to worry about.
Alright here we go.
Here we go.
Woo.
Alright.
It's time to fight.
I have my shotgun.
Mmm.
Ah.
Hahaha.
Mmm.
Okay.
Wait.
What?
I wish I had the flash grenade now.
Okay.
Hehehe.
Woah.
Oh.
It's a guy.
Wait.
I can...
Shake.
I forgot to shake.
I was like.
What is that?
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Shake time.
Shake!
What's this?
Wait.
Wouldn't it be great if I had...
You know...
You know.
If I had...
Nice.
That's good.
It would be so great if I had...
Fucking...
Have the flashbang.
Man.
That would be so convenient.
Okay.
I got this though.
It's okay.
I got this.
Nice.
Oh.
It wasn't as bad as I thought.
Thank God.
It's not as bad as I thought.
Oh.
Thank God.
Is there more?
What the f...
Oh.
I didn't see these two.
Okay.
No.
Reload.
Okay.
Please throw the flame!
Ashley!
Throw the flame!
I'm
holding it!
Ashley!
How did you miss the flame?
I had to lead them, Ashley!
Ashley!
There you go.
Stop being useless.
Ashley, please.
How did you miss?
Oh God.
Ashley, you have...
Did you run out?
Did you run out, Ashley?
Okay.
There you go.
Thank fucking God.
Kick!
Oh!
I didn't waste too much ammo at least.
Oh my...
The moment I said that...
The moment...
The moment I said that, I missed two shots.
What is my life?
Are you okay?
Yeah.
Nighty night.
Nights.
Okay.
We won't pick her up yet.
Okay, now we can.
I have to get the loot.
Classic Ducky.
Yeah, I'm okay.
Don't worry.
With your aim...
I definitely did not get burned.
Oh my God.
Give me the loot.
Give me the fucking loot.
Okay, nice.
Oh hey.
Hey guys, I found the flash grenade.
Guys, don't worry.
Flash grenade next fight.
Chat, the flash...
We can have the flash grenade next fight.
Chat, don't worry.
Just in time.
Okay, let's see.
We gotta open this.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Isn't that so nice that I found it?
Guys, I found it just in time.
Oh nice.
I knew there was a medallion here.
I felt it in my soul.
Not from the map.
It was from the soul.
I don't think they're gonna move, do you?
Oh, I caught the cube.
Wait, the cube.
Right.
Nice.
Nice flick.
That was a good flick.
Not gonna lie.
Alright.
Right here.
Wait, not save yet.
We gotta get the cube.
Cube time.
Oh, okay.
It's a puzzle.
Okay, no.
That's a circle.
Where's the square?
Uh...
How do I...
Oh, here!
Nice.
So smart.
We did it!
The square goes in the square hole.
Okay.
We need the...
What other opens the cube?
I think there's a cube in one of these, right?
Was there a cube treasure here?
Yeah?
Alright, we go back.
It's fast travel time.
Fast travel!
Come over, Ashley.
Ashley.
We're cubing.
I know my shapes.
Hey, this is it!
I know my shapes!
Okay, this way.
Woop!
It's money time.
Guys, we need to upgrade.
We need to upgrade.
It's money time.
Oh, it leads back here.
What the...
Okay.
Hello?
What the...
Okay.
Ashley, get back!
Okay, here we go.
Ashley!
Come move!
Ashley, what are you doing?
Oh my god!
I swear to god, Ashley.
I swear to fucking god.
Ashley, I swear to god.
I swear to god.
I have to reload.
My god.
Ashley, what are you doing?
No problem.
Oh my god.
You hurt?
I'm good, thanks.
Oh my god, what the fuck is Ashley doing?
Jesus Christ.
I swear.
I swear to god, Ashley.
Jesus.
She's just trying to help, donkey.
She was so helpful, chat.
She really was incredibly helpful.
Okay, time to do the cube.
It's cubing time.
God damn it.
Okay, it's this way.
I'm trying to find the circular one.
Oh my god.
Where?
Where is it?
Okay, maybe it's here?
No.
Okay, this is difficult.
Cat.
Too stupid for this.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's Q and E.
There's Q and E!
I didn't realize!
I didn't realize there was Q and E!
I didn't realize there was another rotation!
Okay, I figured it out.
I wasn't reading.
I was just pressing buttons.
Oh my god.
Okay, let me sell this.
Let me sell this.
Okay.
Let's see.
We don't have... Wait, is this circular?
Oh, fuck.
It's circular.
Oh, they're all circles!
I don't have circles!
Okay.
3000.
We need to...
help our fucking thing here.
And then... Our knife is okay right now.
It's okay.
I think I'm gonna save for this.
We need to save up for like...
gun upgrades.
We're gonna save for gun upgrades.
Shapes.
Doki does not do well with shapes.
Okay, we're gonna put this here.
And then...
I'm not gonna fix this.
I'm not gonna fix my inventory.
Alright, we're fine.
Woo!
Yeah!
Alright.
That guy that was like, You're gonna miss the red guy.
I finally now know what he meant by that.
Oh my god.
Los Amigos!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
Nobody cares about what the inventory looks like.
No one cares!
It's still usable.
As long as it's usable.
That's all that matters.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
The last boss.
The puzzle.
The last boss reading.
Right here.
Reading.
The worst boss of them all.
Oh, it's hurting your OCD?
Let me make it better for you.
There you go.
Oh hey, there's a vase there.
Nice.
I'm helpful.
Alright.
This... Oh no!
It's the cube room!
Oh, no.
Not this room.
Okay.
Where are they?
They didn't hear that, right?
Guys, do you think they heard that?
No, right?
I think I'm fine.
I don't think they heard that.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
They didn't hear.
I had a silencer on it.
Try to see where the others are.
I know like...
No!
How did he see me?
What?!
No!
How did I miss too?
What the f-
Boom.
Okay.
Outta the way.
How did I miss?
Shake, shake.
Shut up!
Don't shake!
Do not shake!
I can't be bothered.
Where?
Okay.
He dead?
He dead.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Okay, there we go.
Reloading, reloading, reloading!
Oh shit!
Boom!
Bye.
Oh fuck!
Shit, get over here Ashley.
I'm sorry Ashley.
Shake!
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god, please.
No!
Okay.
Alright.
Kick!
Come on!
Nice.
Shoot you on the leg.
Oh no.
Leg!
Shake!
There we go.
They're all dead.
We're fine.
Thanks.
We're okay.
Shanking always works.
Remember to always shank, guys.
Remember to always shank.
Shank.
There we go.
There's always shanking time.
One more just to...
be sure.
You gotta double shank, man.
You always have to double shank, guys.
Okay.
Where the fuck is that rat?
I'm still missing one more rat.
Almost shanked.
Ashley, she's fine.
If she's not fine, she would tell me.
Right, Ashley?
You would tell Uncle Leon if it's not fine.
You remember that.
Tell Uncle Leon.
If it's not fine, just let me know.
I ran past it?
Where the fuck was the rat?
Wait, there's a green...
Oh, there is a green area.
Nice.
No rats here.
This is a clean area.
This area is clean.
It's clean.
It isn't until after Ashley...
What the fuck do you mean?
What do you mean?
I don't like that.
Okay, here we go.
Nice.
We're doing it, Ashley.
We're fucking doing it.
Okay, we gotta reload our...
We gotta reload our rifle.
Alright.
Up we go.
Can we unlock this door?
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
There we go.
We got the goat head.
Yay!
Oh my god.
Look at all this ammo.
It's like I never wasted anything other than the flash grenade.
What?
Fuck!
Sorry.
That scared the shit out of me.
I wasn't ready for that.
Oh god.
Okay.
I was like, what do you mean watch out?
Like, what do you mean?
I couldn't tell what he meant.
Alright.
Shake!
There we go.
Nice.
She did... Yeah!
Like 20 seconds later!
It's not helpful!
That's not helpful.
Oh, I missed ammo?
Did I?
Oh, I did.
Bro, I missed out like resources and...
Wait!
I missed out on resources and flash grenade!
We gotta go back.
Ashley, we have to go back.
Ashley.
We have to go back.
It's like we never lost anything.
Now it's like we never lost anything!
Look at that!
I'm just blind.
As always, treasure under the bridge.
Oh!
Oh hey, treasure!
Yeah!
Treasure!
It's just a yellow diamond.
That's the shittiest treasure.
And then...
There is shotgun shells.
Wait, where the fuck is that?
Oh, it's like...
Over here?
Where the fuck do I get there?
Oh, it's at the top.
Okay.
Nice.
We're learning, Ashley.
Where is that?
What?
Oh!
It's on the fucking banister!
Sorry, it was on the banister, guys.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, nice.
We did it, Ashley.
We fucking did it.
We're gamers.
We're fucking gamers.
Fucking gaming.
I'm so proud of us.
Ashley, you and I.
You and I against the world.
Okay, we gotta save now.
Oh yeah, we did.
Let's get that request real fast.
Nice!
How much money do I have?
I still don't have a lot.
I'm still broke as fuck.
Uh, yeah, we need like...
Anything?
Will you...
What if I like sell Ashley to him and then like I'll buy Ashley back?
So then like I...
I mean like...
He's everywhere.
So then I don't have to...
What if I pay you to babysit Ashley?
Can I pay him to babysit Ashley?
That'd be so convenient, man.
If he likes money that much.
Like a pawn shop.
A pawn shop?
Alone Ashley.
Wait a minute.
What?
No!
That was the Ashley part!
Not the Ashley chapter.
Nooo!
One fear.
One fucking fear.
Oh no!
No!
One fucking fear!
Yeah!
The nightmare begins!
Oh my god, the true hell awaits!
Real hell.
Alright, here we go.
Oh god, alright, here we go.
Real hell here.
Oh my god, dude, fuck off!
Oh, there's a rat.
Can I fucking punch the rat?
I can't punch the fucking rat, okay.
This is real hell.
Why do you walk so slow?
God, this is the worst part.
This is the worst part.
This is the worst part of this game.
I don't have gun.
I don't know gun.
Hell.
The resting forbearer answers to the chosen time.
If it's the Lord's blessing you seek, have courage.
Oh yeah, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just gonna have courage.
Thank you.
Guys, can I like, guys, please just backseat me.
Please.
Guys, please.
Please, just tell me.
Just tell me.
Please, just tell me the time.
Get me out of here.
Please.
Maybe, guys, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Eventually, I'm gonna be able to do this.
I'll use my wooden keyboard.
Guys, I have an idea.
I have...
Okay, what if...
What if...
Okay, I give up.
Oh, hell.
Actual hell.
I honestly thought it would be a new chapter.
And then I can be like, hee hee, new chapter.
I guess we'll play it next time.
I...
I lose gun.
Now I don't know what to do.
No gun.
No game.
Confused.
What to do when you have no gun.
What do you do?
Oh my god.
What is life without a gun?
I know this section is inspiring any...
She loves this.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Be right back.
Okay.
Okay,
here we go.
Where...
What if...
Oh, I hate this game.
Go fast.
Gotta go fast.
If I go fast, I can't get scared.
I'm scared!
If I keep running.
If I keep running!
Oh hey, I got the key.
Nice.
Wait, what?
The fuck was that?
What was that?
What was that guys?
If I keep running!
No!
Be gone!
Fish!
I don't know!
This!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Elevator.
Elon!
Okay, here we go.
Oh no.
Just, please... get me out!
Where's Leon?
I'm still running!
He told me to run and I'm still running.
No, I'm not.
I'm not okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Devastator, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, the insignia.
The key to getting out of this confined place is the Salazar family insignia.
The final must venture to where the cursed armor awaits.
The underground...
Oh no, not the underground.
Oh, merciful Lord.
And that your righteous justice upon the wicked usurper.
The maniacal monster, Raymond Salazar.
And may your blessed blue light protect you forever, you faithful servant.
Oh no, come on.
Yes, this is it.
This is it.
We can figure this out.
We can...
This is it.
This is... 1104!
Okay.
That's...
Wait.
I did it.
I knew it would eventually work.
I knew it would eventually work, guys.
I fucking knew it.
Does this mean I can skip everything now?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is it.
This is it.
This is not it.
Nice is not it.
Wait, what?
Okay, we're gonna shine this.
And then...
Shine!
Where am I?
Oh, I have to go all the way back!
Don't look back!
Where's the clock?
1104!
There we go.
We did it.
We did it, guys.
We're gamers.
I can't believe it.
1104.
I speedrun!
I don't know, I just figured it out.
Guys...
I just...
I just kept... I just knew.
Come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Okay.
And then we go.
Oh, shit!
No!
Guys, no one likes Ashley levels!
No one likes the Ashley levels!
Don't f***ing pretend!
Don't be righteous with me right now!
Don't act all f***ing righteous.
What's this?
Eagle... wait, what is this?
Wait, that's everything.
Eagle, fish, snake, crow.
I like it right now.
Well, I'm doing it!
Are you not entertained?
Yeah, same Ashley.
Finally, I can relate to you!
Finally, some relatability!
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god!
I'm ready!
Oh my god, please!
Get me out of here!
Oh my god, I'm here!
What's this?
Moon... okay, moon...
What is this?
Is this a star or a moon?
Oh wait, no...
Oh my god, it's right here.
Oh my god, okay.
Moon... star...
This is it?
No?
Not the right moon?
How is there a min- how...
How are there more moons?
Oh, there we go.
That was a big moon.
Okay, I had the wrong moon.
I sound tired?
I'm playing Ashley, man.
Anybody will be tired playing this level.
I feel like I aged 80 years playing Ashley.
Oh god, oh god, tell me I just ran!
No!
Come on!
Ashley, don't look back!
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, I mean, let me just use this key, I guess.
Guys, this is important.
Guys, don't worry.
We're gonna figure out the key.
Guys, this is very important.
We got an emerald, guys.
This is so important.
We got an emerald.
Good nights, and stay still.
Guys, this is important.
This is important.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Get up!
Oh god.
Oh fuck!
This is good.
This is bad.
Press the elevator!
Press the button!
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Alright, here I am.
I don't know where to go.
Where do I go?
Where?
How do I get there?
Okay.
How do I?
What?
There we go.
Just keep running.
Where do I go?
Do I?
Do I go here?
Here?
I don't know where to go!
Here!
Straight!
Do I go straight?
Where's the blue light?
I don't know where to go!
No, don't go straight.
Library!
I swear, I feel like you're fucking with me right now.
Library and up the stairs.
Here?
Here!
Yes!
Okay.
Here.
Not there?!
I'm so confused!
What?!
Go back?!
Oh my god!
Where?!
I got baited?!
Okay.
This is it.
Here.
Here!
Almost there!
We're doing it, Ashley!
The power of back seating!
Where?
Oh, here!
Let me out!
Oh my god!
The power of back seating!
Run, girl!
Run!
Holy fuck!
God damn it!
Oh shit, man!
I hate this thing!
I actually love all of them!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy!
Oh!
Thank god!
Leon, please give me your gun!
Leon!
No!
Ashley!
What happened?
After everything I did!
After everything, Ashley!
Oh my god!
He turned his back for literally two seconds!
Fucking Ashley, man!
Fucking Ashley!
Oh!
What the
fuck is... what?
What is that?
That's... that's Ashley, right?
A for Ashley.
I know like Ada is supposed to be like some fucking assassin.
Like some robot assassin.
But like I don't like the voice acting.
Or how mechanical she sounds.
Is that Wesker?
Alright.
Hey Ada.
I just went through hell.
Oh god, it was...
It was so hard.
Oh my god.
Alright, we're calling it here.
I think... I honestly think this is a... this is a good place to call it.
I think...
I honestly think this is a...
this is a good place to call it.
Oh my god.
Bro.
After... after the Ashley part, I'm done.
We'll finish the game.
We'll finish... we'll finish Resident Evil next... next week, guys.
We're gonna finish Resident Evil next week.
All it took was the Ashley level.
Yes.
100%.
Ashley level is what is... what makes or breaks the game.
The Ashley level is what ages me like...
I'm insane.
The moment we're at the Ashley level, I'm mentally checked out.
I'm so fucking checked out, guys.
Anyway.
I think I really lost it.
The chat's coming in.
So I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
I am really tired now.
From...
Like I was fine.
I was fine until... until Ashley.
Then I was not so fine anymore.
But yeah!
Also, I guess a little update.
A little update.
You guys just don't follow me on Twitter.
If you purchase the buttons, the pinback buttons for the Lunar New Year merch, they will be shipped out sooner than the estimated shipping date.
Because I have a... like those like... those like button makers.
And I make them myself.
So like... they will be shipped out soonish.
So yeah!
I look forward to that.
If you guys...
If you guys like... ordered...
Only for the buttons though.
If you ordered like other items with the buttons, they'll be shipped when the other items are there.
But you only ordered the buttons, then like they'll be shipped out sooner.
So yeah!
That's the only other things I have for all of you guys.
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
I am so exhausted from fucking Ashley level.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!